oh my god welcome to fat man I Batman
Kevin Smith hi I'm Marc menorah we are
as always live right here at the scum
and villainy Cantina on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California put
your hands together so the audience at
all knows you're real and we really are
it feels very scum and villainy right
now dead ahead of me hopefully they'll
cut to a shot of it or something but if
you're not here in the room you're
really [ __ ] missing something special
I know he's got like a technical name
but I always knew him as the figure that
I bought hammerhead hammerhead is here
with us today from a new hope for the
best damn cosplaying version of
hammerhead I've ever seen what was his
name when they gave him a real names
anybody no see hammerhead so much better
[ __ ] up and in space they wouldn't
bother to [ __ ] be like what's your
name they just Billy he looks like a
[ __ ] hammer so I always bought that
but that's wonderful man is it a tough
uncomfortable cosplay are you gonna are
you committed to staying in it all show
is it's to our show I mean I know I'm
cosplaying as Silent Bob but I mean
that's that seems like a much heavier
costume all right that cannot be you
know as a guy who likes a performance I
commit your I admire your commitment to
the performance man that's the best
acting I've seen since like [ __ ] ever
maybe since Justin long was like yeah
I'll be the walrus like that depict on
par with that [ __ ] well done
um alright man that just warms my heart
I [ __ ] I'll be honest with you I'm
stoned enough to say this I [ __ ] love
doing the show here I love this space
the I love the show but the show a
[ __ ] really blew up for me when we
found this space and we didn't find it
JC built it and stuff so I love coming
here and the other night I was just
tooling around with my kid in the car
like my wife sent us out she's like you
got to take her to Westwood and so if
there was a plan to go to Westwood and
then go to like [ __ ] Dave & Buster's
maybe on the way back and then she
flipped it and went to Dave & Buster's
we just wound up hanging out and like
she's actually she kind of likes doing
what I do like I Drive up in the hills
Hollywood Hills and stuff I love the
view of over my Holland and so as I was
driving around and I just listened to
music and [ __ ] with her she goes oh this
is where I hang out with my friends and
I'm like I always pass here in couples
Park and like make out and she's like
yeah that's me and I was like holy [ __ ]
this is amazing so at one point like I
was sitting here blowing up the bar tour
I was like [ __ ] JC's bar is amazing
blah blah blah she's like can we go and
she's 18 and stuff so I called JC man
and be like hey like I'm are you working
tonight and he's like no but I come to
the bar because there's what is it all
ages till 9 o'clock or some [ __ ]
I'm some night till 9:00 so what does
that mean for the folks at home like if
they just want to come and drink soda
that's what happens till 9:00 is that
what all ages means or E so it like for
kid people like I would love to bring my
kid but I can you know my kids [ __ ]
nine there's a period to come where you
just eat food take pictures and [ __ ]
like that
genius unless your kid is drew Barrymore
in which case she'll be here to drink
that's true
drinkin smokin we've all seen the
pictures so so I said I'm gonna roll up
on the bar and god bless her either she
is a really good actress or she had
never been to a bar before like she was
like a kid out of a movie where it's
like I've come from space and I'm like
let's go to a bar and she's like people
do this like gather and
look how happy they are and the music is
fun she's so either that or she was her
performance was pitch perfect and she's
like dad I'm 18 I've been to many
[ __ ] bars but but she was she loved
the place she's like is this one a bar
is like and I was like no not at all oh
my god Christ no I've been to many
[ __ ] bars with uncle Jason back in
the day and they are not [ __ ] cool
like this like this space is chill man
that night we didn't even have a show
here it was me coming to the bar just to
kind of show it off to her and so and
the crowd was like really wonderful and
they were playing like [ __ ] music
from like I think they were playing you
know of from pretty and pink attached
you once I touch you twice you know I
came in with my teenage daughter I was
like this couldn't be more perfect
you know so I love this place with all
my I think it's did you [ __ ] a good idea
I'm happy for JC and and Jen and his
whole crew that it's taken off this was
meant to be like a pop up experience God
and it's legit like it's got a home on
Hollywood Boulevard you know how [ __ ]
hard it is to open anything in
California let alone this town awesome
alright so enough blown the [ __ ] bar
we're just coming off of Thanksgiving
and we're heading toward another holiday
which we'll talk about in a minute
uh-huh how was your Thanksgiving my fix
even was awesome except for the fact
that Thanksgiving morning my my oven
shot to bed
how it just stopped working yeah you can
have that thank you so you got the real
thing Oh juice you can have that
yeah just shot the [ __ ] bed and we're
sitting there with a 20-pound turkey and
my in-laws and we're ready to rumble and
we have no oven that's the nightmare
scenario than what happens what do you
do well first there was tears and then
there was rage what was taking the oven
like Fonzie hoping maybe it would work
and then there was a neighbor who said
hey you can use our oven we're going out
for Thanksgiving so oh my god this is
like a Hallmark Channel well seriously
is like [ __ ] just worked out that's
beautiful it's like there's a there's a
[ __ ] barn and then we can have a baby
in their barn they were totally cool
with it
now they invite us into and we invaded
their oven and I bake
on my grill which you can actually do I
make an apple pie on my grill that's a
thing you can actually yeah I'm here to
change anything nope just a lad I turn
on your grill to like 350 and put up a
high on you you turn on one side of your
grill 350 you put the pie on the other
side of the grill so and you just keep
it closed for like two hours and you'll
have a [ __ ] pie at the end of that
necessity being the mother of invention
I learned I've heard this [ __ ] on you
really [ __ ] impressive I would have
been the other guy going we're all gonna
Taco Bell boyo loco delivered today
I I dream of going to a restaurant on
Thanksgiving like that I think that
sounds cool I know people who do it on
my boo that sounds cool and classy but I
do like the idea of leftovers and I'm
packed with them I [ __ ] easily gain
15 pounds in two days eating as much
[ __ ] Thanksgiving turkey mashed
potatoes and I just kept making the
sandwich the traditional sandwich like
well you know I love the meal itself but
then later on the sandwiches like two
pieces are widest ass white bread on the
planet [ __ ] turkey gravy and mashed
potatoes some people put on dressing but
why the [ __ ] would you put jelly on
mashed potatoes I take that sandwich I
[ __ ] I'd rather eat and [ __ ] I'll be
honest with you when it comes to the
post Thanksgiving sandwich man and
nobody wants to [ __ ] me post
Thanksgiving because I'm all trip to
find out like oh you could [ __ ] the
sandwich this is no way and pie-eyed
stayed away from sugar but my
mother-in-law Gail makes amazing coconut
custard pie and so like I was like oh
I'll take a little piece which turned
into half a pie which turned into me on
Saturday night go hon can you make
another pie
and then me trying to finish that pie
before the Sunday cutoff which becomes
Monday where I'm like now it's time
together but that's not the big holiday
that's the [ __ ] over with man yeah
we're done with that the big holiday
coming up is on Wednesday tell them what
it is mark barnard n' it's my birthday
[Applause]
now what are you saying what birthday it
is are you being coy
[Music]
46 46 gonna be 46 I'm 45 now so last
birthday had you written on the show yet
no so you start so this birthday this
has been a hell of a year and big year
for you man agir next year can only go
downhill from here I was kind of being a
little more hopeful without it like
these the beginning of good times you
like it'll never get better than this
[ __ ] we're moving into an RV honey it's
over well you got any wisdom for the
folks on your big 40 you know [ __ ]
it's never too late to you free song
happy birthday happy birthday mark
barnard and I'm gonna eat that Twinkie
happy birthday
that's awesome thank you everybody
too [ __ ] sweet Thank You Melissa yay
Make A Wish blow out the candles man
good folks here at the Barclays mark an
assortment of hosting like this bag and
a gift bag holy [ __ ] you're getting
gifts Wow
blow out the candles make a wish okay
hold on don't wish for a better co-host
giving a bag Nathan you give them a bag
what's in it
watch it what is that key auntie can't
are there fava beans in here to a 20
year old Chianti Wow great
Pez sweet Green Lantern Pez Hal Jordan
salmon twitch research jinger's crossed
and a post car thank you allowed to read
it out loud or is it like intimate like
mark I want to see your dick no no there
you go please enjoy this wine that is
hopefully as well as you have may it
serve is inspiration for future projects
or as celebration for once completed you
rock the multiverse your spider friend
Nathan Zales Thank You Nathan let's race
me it's it's not creepy that Nathan and
I are literally dressed the same you see
you look like mini-me much Menier me
what are you gonna do on the actual day
I'm gonna continue to eat my face off
fuckin'-a as my want I will write
because the [ __ ] else am I gonna do
I may play some video games cuz now go
no responsibilities are gonna job to go
to so hey I'm gonna eat and write and
play video games I might not even get
dressed
sounds like the ideal birth yes maybe
get some maternity pants just to make
more room you call maternity pants if I
call them pants
[Laughter]
yeah now it's been a really good year
it's been it's been a year of not being
afraid of [ __ ] it's been a year of
realizing that it's actually never too
late you know that that there is no age
limit no statute of limitations on
dreams
fuckin'-a and just [ __ ] reach for it
man every now and again you'll grab it
more often than not you'll fall flat on
your face but that's okay and remind
them the leap that you had to make I
left what was at the time a 20-year
journalism career as a editor and writer
and pop culture blah blah blah to become
a TV writer to be a dude who gets to
make this [ __ ] up as opposed to writing
about the [ __ ] that other people make up
a key difference and also the move was a
big thing as well your Jersey well in
East Coaster New Jersey you were living
in Jersey I was living in Jersey yeah
but you weren't born in Jersey born I
was born on boogie down bronx baby
[Laughter]
so wait born and branch but you were
living in Jersey and you had to make a
decision to move out here did you do it
it was you know it was a Trojan horse
The Hollywood Reporter moved me out here
knowing full well that I was going to
leave them like in a hot minute if I got
a better job and and it was it was a big
deal pulling my family out from the sort
of warm bosom of New Jersey and bringing
them out to Los Angeles which they did
not like at first because it's Los
Angeles
Marx lady is literally from my neck of
the woods yes like she went to a high
school that was in our basketball
division totally like we she would
remember watching your movies is there
clown is on the wrong side of the street
yeah that's [ __ ] oh yeah there's
Bethenny Drive I know what Bethenny
drive is rum yeah that's right man she
could point out errors and [ __ ] one like
when you put a movie together you're
like well this just makes sense
editorially but you don't think about
like I'm from here and any one will give
a [ __ ] because I'm the only pedantic
person from that area who would be like
oh that's wrong but thanks to the
internet everybody is that [ __ ] a
banach person and so not even just
locals told me the clowns on the wrong
[ __ ] side is like people is like I'm
not even from there and I'm
the clowns on the wrong [ __ ] side a
Google Earth that [ __ ] yeah it's true
man Google's [ __ ] defeating me yeah
yeah man but just every now and again
you got a you got a sack up and and do
the thing that scares you the most
and every now and again it'll pay off
that's a big move to man move in the
it's one thing we need to do it solo
moving an entire family and whatnot
yeah commitment you've got support there
indeed good people yeah and you're all
lovely also did you think I was lying
stuck on you calling your family good
people good people I have to write [ __ ]
down because oh this is important to
[ __ ] say George Carlin told me that
George Carlin not that thing George
Carlin said write everything down I was
like why he goes number one you've
become a stoner he goes but number two
he's gone that is the key to every piece
of success I've ever had is something
I've written down because all the [ __ ]
that I forgot to write down he's going I
could have been much better at what I do
and stuff so I always remember to write
[ __ ] down now one of the things we have
to talk about is next week we have a
show here on Monday correct Tuesday
Tuesday on the fifth so tickets be on
sale by the time you hear this but
here's a non ticketed free way to see
the show what two days later on the 7
p.m. it there's a benefit there's hear
it for those who don't have never been
out here even if you've never been out
here you probably saw way back in the
day when the Star Wars movies were being
you know there's Regals well I think
they did it back in the back in like 77
78 but then when there's special
editions came out they've kind of redid
it again yeah yeah
[ __ ] used to line up for months at a
time outside of what was then Grauman's
Chinese Theater and later on Mann's
Chinese Theater and now the TCL Chinese
Theatre
and you know that's where the footprints
are in the cement and all that [ __ ]
right on Hollywood Boulevard line up for
for Star Wars the the one that I
remember I
tr4 was 99 yeah the prequels when the
prequels came out there were a line of
people like literally [ __ ] hanging
out outside for months they built little
tents and [ __ ] like that
so I love that as that shows big
commitment I'd never [ __ ] do it I
like showering so I didn't but I can
respect people that make that kind of
commitment and whatnot and they always
wind up on the news and [ __ ] like this
is really a spectacle so and in a good
way so now like and this is something I
literally just learned in the alley
before the film again you don't have to
do that anymore
no no advance sales and you can pick
your seat and you can buy that [ __ ]
months in advance if you want I had no
idea but they're still lining up they
are but for a different reason not
because the like we have to because
they're like you know this is what we do
yeah like this choice we choose to do
this symbolic it ties into when they did
it back in the 90s late 90s for the
prequels and stuff but I would just
baffle them like seriously you don't
have to do that like just go online and
buy a ticket dick and I'm like is that
how you do it why do you have to be so
hostile
so yeah the right to be hostile yes that
was mark so so the Starlight Children's
Foundation is the beneficiary of the
good folks who are lining up again in in
vain in front of the Chinese Theatre in
advance of the last Jedi which comes out
on December 14th
correct what could be the night of the
14th official opening date is Friday the
15th so yes absolutely hey someone else
is [ __ ] pedantic way to be that's
right it does come out on the 15th
that's what the posters say but Thursday
is officially opening nights of the 14th
midnight showings at 6:00 p.m. we're
splitting wookie hairs at this point in
advance of that these good folks are
lining up again there's going to spend
two weeks out in front of the Chinese
Theater
a lot of people from the original group
mm-hmm and they do it now to raise money
for the Starlight Children's Foundation
so apparently what they're doing is
since they're lining up every night
they've got some [ __ ] going on
for the people lined up entertainment
little less traction and we are gonna be
part of the entertainment so they asked
us December 7th is the first night of
the lineup event to do fat man on Batman
this is where it gets [ __ ] cool in
the courtyard of the Chinese Theater
they're gonna build a little stage and
we just sit there on footprints as Mark
said what standing on the footprints of
giants and do this [ __ ] show so that
happens on December 7th anybody can go
it's free right I think you could just
[ __ ] walk up and watch if you want
and what we're gonna do though we'll
pass the Hat though for the Starlight
Children's Foundation so bring cash and
if you're like hey and I'm gonna cash
don't worry we'll take credit cards as
well and raise a little money for those
cats paw over there so free show two
days after the show that you pay forward
to see here we'll go down the street and
do a free show a special show it has to
be very Star Wars centric I think that's
what these cats were lined up for we
can't big get up there and be like hey
would you think of Justice League [ __ ]
you I'm giving up two weeks of my life
for kids and Star Wars talking about far
got nine um people like 9 them yeah man
all right enough deep cuts jokes that
that happens December 7th there's no way
to buy tickets again I can't send you to
a website but you just show up you could
watch I'm imagining 8 p.m. standard roll
time and come on over
I asked us we're on the street we're
literally just and and and there's not
it's not just us like there's a few
nights where the like now they're doing
virtual reality like dave & buster's is
bringing down star wars themed video
games like every night they're kind of
providing entertainment and [ __ ] and I
was like oh [ __ ] so this is like when
like the USO has entertainers come over
like they're like the USO and me and
Mark are like Bob Hope and [ __ ] like so
it's kind of like what it is which one
of us is Marilyn Monroe see you for sure
so I guess that's that's gonna happen
next week what is that Thursday
Wednesday Thursday Thursday December 7
beautiful so mark your calendars come on
out and see the show bring out and bring
it why I think it'll be [ __ ] chilly
last last week was 140 degrees in Los
Angeles and today it's 50 degrees so I
know hot hail could be coming next
Thursday it is inexplicable swamp-ass
it's a screenplay I was working on
before I got here swamp ass
there's a swamp ass front coming in off
the water at the West what was I going
to say I looked at my notes and it was
about Oh [ __ ] Runaways yeah I watched
all three episodes I didn't think I'd
want to watch at least one because we
had Ryan on the show last night sans my
papa Walt Wilder who's really [ __ ]
dope on the show yeah like sympathetic
dope but also like [ __ ] evil dope so
I thought I'd watch one but they're so
[ __ ] insanely well done I watched all
three and the next one drops to use the
kids terminology tonight at nine o'clock
so when I leave here I'm gonna go home
and watch that [ __ ] it is so [ __ ]
well done it's charming a [ __ ] yeah it's
not like it doesn't speak down to its
characters they feel like current
teenagers I got one so I'm like wow this
is [ __ ] close she went through her
witch phase as well and she stuff like
that just walked the craft over and over
and over and totally so a lot of skulls
in the room that was one thing they
start panning around this chick's room a
lot of skulls I was like I remember when
my kid was the skull girl like
everywhere it was such an easy Christmas
for like here you go
skulls was that when she was a bass
player too it's true here you go bass
yeah and she was deep in the bass cold I
wish death on Silent Bob keep practicing
honey it sounds great
Silent Bob I never watched The OC I was
never an OC guy that's what I noticed
the credits the co-creator of the show
is Josh and Stephanie Savage I think and
they were the other person Stephanie
Savage I believe her she co-creator on
the OC or he's the only one I think he's
the only one but they have since worked
together on a bunch of stuff is there
really something I don't know or
something you know it all am i putting
you on the spot you totally are [ __ ]
move on move
there's no point Ron there's but he's
really strong writers creator cuz I
honestly fell in love with the show
pretty quickly and Mark was saying in
the alleyways looks like maybe it's time
for me to go watch The OC yeah I never
did I just did it it glossed over me
when I was in at that [ __ ] age or
then again I was also 35 when the OC
came out so I was never that age when I
was on TV but I just said I I like good
teen entertainment I like when you're
telling stories about kids where again
you're not talking down to the kids with
a legit characters and they want things
and they feel things and everything they
do was motivated by what feels like teen
logic and then you add [ __ ] evil
nightmare parents and cults and rituals
murders and [ __ ] that's that's real
spoiler spoilers episode 1 ends with
like a [ __ ] ritualistic killing where
the kids are like holy [ __ ] mom yeah and
they accidentally take a picture and
[ __ ] and like they fart you know what
it's like it's like kind of like there's
a movie I [ __ ] love from the 70s man
I don't know I think they remade it I
can't remember they were talking about
remaking it it's called race with the
devil do you ever see that no Jesus
Peter Fonda and Warren Oates and if you
read your cinema history it only got
made because Peter Fonda is like we can
go ride motorcycles in the desert [ __ ]
it and they all went out and made this
movie it's him
it's Peter Fonda Warren Oates Loretta
Swit and I forget the fourth person's
name the other woman so the idea is
there they got a Winnebago and they're
out in the middle of nowhere [ __ ]
literally just doing jumps with [ __ ]
dirt bikes you know middle-aged guys and
[ __ ] and so you know but seeing amount
of dirt a bike of any sort this was
[ __ ] Captain America Easy Rider
himself Peter Fonda so I guess there was
the draw that's how you sell that movie
you're like it's [ __ ] Captain America
he's back on a motorcycle miss Tommy's
fighting Satan and and that's what
happens like when they're all in a
Winnebago and they're [ __ ] jumping
the dunes and [ __ ] and then they have a
little like nighttime pit like [ __ ]
fireside picnic or whatever the [ __ ] you
call just sitting there drinking coffee
to chitchat and having a good time and
then they hear off in the distance like
[ __ ] music and they see a fire in the
distance maybe they didn't have a fire
he had a fires on the other side
the Winnebago Light so they're like
let's go look and they go closer and you
know it's the big flame in the middle
and [ __ ] and there's a bunch of people
in robes and they'll you know this is
the 70s so Satan's pretty new like you
know if we if any of us saw this in like
from a mile away be like Satanist let's
go the other way but these cats are like
let's look and they're looking in the
Litoral and robes and [ __ ] and they
can't figure anything I feel like why
are they doing this then they take off
the robes and then they look oh it's an
orgy and [ __ ] like that but then they
bring out this girl and they [ __ ]
tire up or layer down I forget and they
[ __ ] stab her they sacrifice her and
[ __ ] and one of the women I love it's
Loretta Swit or the other one like
reacts like weird screams or whatever
[ __ ] and they all [ __ ] turn at once
you know and then Peter Fonda is like
let's get the [ __ ] out of here and they
run to the Winnebago and take the [ __ ]
off and no Akoo that was a close one
that's [ __ ] act 1 act 2 you find out
that they didn't get away at all these
[ __ ] Satanists are all over their
[ __ ] dude and like everything is
terrifying like they [ __ ] like it's
every step of the way there's somebody
there looking at him suspiciously and
they have to stop it's really charming
like you'd have to rewrite this entire
part but at one point in the movie
they're like what is this cult and so
they go to a [ __ ] local library and
they look up satanic and they look up
ritual and [ __ ] like that and they're
like there are people that believe in
the devil like they have literally given
you expository dialogue the Tobin's
spirit guide here maybe we can just I'm
telling you it's like Satan 101 for
dummies because like they have to
presuppose the audience doesn't know
jack [ __ ] and so these Satanists chased
him across the country I don't want to
spoil it but I do want to tell you the
ending image so I will [ __ ] spoil it
like they get away like there's [ __ ]
tons of like their [ __ ] clothes and
[ __ ] and they finally get away and you
know like they're safe in the middle of
nowhere and [ __ ] I know like who thank
God like it's it's all over and then all
of a sudden of like it's beautiful shot
[ __ ] Ring of Fire surrounds the
Winnebago in the night just and then you
see the [ __ ] Satanist chanting
outside they're like credits they knew
how to end a movie in the [ __ ]
seventies man
there was no like and they all lived
happily ever after like all these [ __ ]
will die you just don't get to see it
and you got to use your imaginations I'm
a whole young life I was like what did
they do did they [ __ ] eventually run
out of the Winnebago and then the
Satanist caught him and stabbed him to
death or they shoot him from it like wow
how does it and you know I'd sit there
for hours and [ __ ] back when I had an
imagination
so that reminded me that aspect of it
really [ __ ] caught my eye like
eventually their their parents they see
their parents up to the [ __ ] really
no good and not it's a [ __ ] kid show
and for them to like kill somebody or at
least that's what it appears to be you
know it's kind of [ __ ] dope but then
their parents see them they all turn and
they don't see them but they saw a flash
of light and [ __ ] so then there's a
cat-and-mouse game between the parents
and the kids like do they know how much
do they know and stuff as the parents
are as the kids are also finding out
what their parents abilities are and
what they can do and what they have done
it's really [ __ ] crazily well done I
show that wasn't even on my radar at all
no I went the other way I went the the
it's a show that fundamentally is kind
of about when you stumble upon your
parents having sex
and like that I like my Satan [ __ ]
make you better Maddie that's just too
psychological is like yeah [ __ ] Satan
[ __ ] but it said that thing where
you're you're repulsed by it and yet
also kind of [ __ ] curious about it
because ah but but Lou
but hey kind of all at once you and I
had different childhoods I would only do
that when I opened the fridge like huh
never occurred I never heard my parents
[ __ ] my entire time I lived at 21
Jackson Street I told my mother that
just recently and she goes I know tiger
you've told me the whole time I was
there and never are they're affectionate
with one another you know I saw him kiss
never heard him [ __ ] in my entire life
assumed they stopped because I was the
last child so but my mom says no that
was not the case they were just quiet my
dad was the original Silent Bob jokes
are always the best okay so what were we
talking about oh I was insane you went I
went tumbling in on your parents seven
six yeah that's a weird interpretation
I'll be honest with you usually I'm like
you're so [ __ ] smart but I didn't see
that at all because especially because
the kids are like they're not like like
intrigued they're like holy [ __ ] like
let's try to keep [ __ ] normal but you
know it is called which is exactly what
it's like if you stumble on your parents
having sex and the next day you got to
keep [ __ ] normal does anyone run away
because they [ __ ] saw their parents
having sex because I don't somehow your
parents having sex it's true you're like
I saw I'm doing BUTT STUFF I had to get
the [ __ ] out of there good hammerhead
mask in the Hammerhead best have you
ever [ __ ] in the costume
hammerhead literally Suga said no now
you gotta try it dude come on I get a
little Mon Mothma action happenin and
then hammer head just [ __ ] weird head
[ __ ] go to dog no you got to pick
another cantina denizen man you'd have
to pick like [ __ ] Greedo that'd be hot
see not sure minds think alike right
there except when it comes to the
runaways you're way off about that
alright [ __ ] it it's charming as [ __ ]
have you watched all three no now only
you ever seen the first one oh [ __ ]
yeah which I thought the premiere I oh
you saw it someplace yeah alright you
know I I thought it was so good that I
just kept [ __ ] watching watching
watching so I will go watch tonight when
I get home I'm happy to have a new
program that and search party I'm diggin
the [ __ ] out of if you haven't watched
search party it it's [ __ ] weird it's
very original especially like
considering its TBS show you're like wow
they're taking chances it makes you want
to go to TBS and pitch some weird [ __ ]
cuz you're like if you did search party
you will definitely do tusk the series
or something like that
okay we're on our ways that's what I had
to talk about and then I got one other
thing on my agenda that's newsworthy and
then we'll go into the news that you've
provided they announced this week I had
no idea they were announcing it but I
was delighted they did it I was
delighted by the reaction that I got
I've for years have called him Mark
Millar apparently not the case no Marlar
literally just Mark Miller but I'm like
it's got an A not an E and they're like
[ __ ] it it's Scottish stop stop trying
to figure it out and [ __ ] so I've been a
fan it's tough for me to change but like
it's weird to say Mark Miller to me but
I called him Mark Millar for so long I
got to keep going with it wrong or not
you know I once ran into a dude whose
name was spelled Bo OTE
and I wanted to call him boot because at
the very least that is a dude some
dignity yeah what are you corrected me
no it's booty I was like [ __ ]
just rolled with the boot it's so much
better of its boot it's actually got to
be booty man Scott booty that's his name
Scott booty yeah sounds totally made
[Laughter]
so mark I've loved Marc's work for years
when going back to when he did this run
on Swamp Thing at DC which really
[ __ ] honored the runs of Swamp Thing
that had gone before he referenced the
Swamp Thing attack on Gotham right then
and there he owned my heart I was a holy
[ __ ] this guy remembers I should so and
this is going back to like 90s I think
he did that 95 96 or something so I
remember being a fan and meeting him at
a con because he showed me pages of what
would eventually be read son that's
another book that he did at DC way back
in the day classic story of what
happened if Superman landed in Soviet
Union instead of America Soviet Union in
Soviet Union kryptonite land on you old
reference so wonderful [ __ ] book I
got to know him through the cons I was
always like dude you're [ __ ] writing
is I love your Swamp Thing he has gone
on to do many [ __ ] things after his
stellar run at DC he went over Marvel
created the ultimate wall at Marvel he'd
worked on it we created old man Logan
there's no Logan movie as we know it
without that he touched a lot of [ __ ]
over and I mean good in a good way not
in a shitty way he touched a lot of
[ __ ] characters over at Marvel and
changed made a difference and then they
had a prince
an imprint called icon or something like
that where you could do creator own [ __ ]
and that's where him and John Romita Jr
did kick-ass which led eventually to
wanted which led to the Secret Service
Kingsman the Secret Service all free of
maternity motion picture properties he
just sold Millar world or Miller little
world apparently to to Netflix I think
we talked about two hundred million
dollars or something that godly and no
no they've never bought somebody's whole
catalog before so that was kind of huge
anyway sweetest [ __ ] dude in the
world and and talented as [ __ ] built
does not only worked on [ __ ] [ __ ]
other people created DC and Marvel
literally one created his own universe
so always been a sweet dude drop me an
email
cuz we zoom out quite a bit back in the
day and stuff and then he got you know
way [ __ ] and famous and busy and [ __ ]
so he dropped me an email going hey I'm
bringing hit-girl back to comics like
I'm gonna do a hip girl series and it's
set in Columbia I'm gonna do with a
bunch of different writers and artists
I was wondering like do you think you'd
ever want to take a run it I think you'd
be good with the character and you know
I was like [ __ ] another job that I'll
disappoint somebody on you know I'm both
sides where I'll be late for it and then
when the reader gets at the be like why
did I [ __ ] take another chance on
this [ __ ] but I was like [ __ ] man
like that would be fun like that mean I
got it I had a cool story for it and
stuff so I was like you know I'm a now
totally doing he was like are you
serious and I was like yeah and so they
just announced it fairly recently last
week who's putting it out do you know
I'd have to think it's image I think me
because that's where all his stuff ya
know so his characters yeah because he
owned Marvel had nothing to do with
kick-ass the movie or anything like that
it's just where they published it
through the icon imprint but the idea
the icon imprint was kind of like their
version of image correct right it was
basically so that
Bendis didn't go to image to do powers
and so powers was the first icon book
and then hit girl rolled up kick-ass
rolled up under that mmm and then once
everybody left and I kind of went away
they all had the rights back to their
characters so they went wherever they
wanted to and so yeah image is not
putting out all that stuff so he's done
kick-ass one two and three and Hit Girl
is a big part of all of it so there he
wants to do it just hit girls series of
books so he's doing Columbia I'm doing
the next four which is set in Los
Angeles and it's when they announced it
I wasn't ready I didn't know what was
happening but when I saw a pop up in my
Twitter feed I got [ __ ] nauseous cuz
I'm like oh god here comes all the bile
here comes the hey why would you let
this guy near a [ __ ] combo he made
Batman piss himself whatever the [ __ ]
they always like to say and [ __ ]
but they didn't react like that most
people are like this makes sense
he should [ __ ] write that character
and stuff so it was kind of nice man I
told mark I was like I I couldn't
believe that there was a lot of hate for
the idea and he said no there's a
definitely a reservoir of love for
in the world of comics he's oh just
don't [ __ ] it up so so I've been I've
been working on it always fine it's fun
to dive back down that a comic book
writing well because it's a lot more
writing than I'm used to writing if I
write a screenplay
generally I'm going to direct it myself
so I'll write a [ __ ] ton a dialogue but
the kind of informational passages
descriptive passages of just like he
walks into the room
pretty damn basic because I'll be the
guy directing it so just on the day I'll
just [ __ ] say what was in my head but
first script that you're handing over to
somebody to draw you have to overwrite
you have to make sure this is everything
I see in my head because you can't
assume that the artist knows what you've
got in your head you know and I'm saying
you got to put it out on script the same
time you can't override it to a point
where the artist is like Jesus dude can
I be a little bit creative on the page
you know you got to let them give some
space to this decent balance to it but
there's a lot more writing involved than
there is in what I'm normally used to
doing I forgot that aspect of it of like
oh yeah I got a hobo write this [ __ ] it
is one of the hardest forms to write in
know you got a book on the stands right
now yeah but called genius cartel out
with that top common image and it's it's
a lot of fun to do what I always like
writing comics but my brain hurts when I
do it because when you write prose it's
just [ __ ] prose you're writing first
person third person whatever that is if
you're writing a screenplay like you
said it's mostly it's about the dialogue
and you're just moving people from place
to place and giving what information you
need so that the costume department
knows what people are wearing or
whatever the [ __ ] right but comics you
write [ __ ] when you write a script do
you write you know you know Kevin Smith
comma [ __ ] 46 47 you know more
confident than he looks or whatever like
I read scripts sometimes when I write
that [ __ ] where I'm like [ __ ] I
just need a book move the [ __ ] on Mike I
don't I don't want to know what you
think this dude thinks of himself
I know actors don't like that [ __ ] yeah
I mean I think that that half the time
that's a sales tool so that executives
know what you're aiming for less than
actors
and production but it stays as part of
the script and then eventually an actor
is like are you [ __ ] serious or
actress yeah but with comics it's like
alright how many pages are in this book
22 how many panels are on each page how
many words are in each panel like you do
in math you're doing storyboarding
you're doing dialogue you're doing drama
like it's it's the hardest [ __ ] thing
I've ever had to write because it's it's
it's working both macro and micro at the
same time well you're both telling a
larger story which in and of itself is a
piece of another larger story but like
how the [ __ ] how many panels should it
be for this dude to open a door you know
that could be one panel it could be
three panels what makes more sense
you're dealing with time dilation and
it's it's it's [ __ ] hard it makes my
brain hurt and then again it also has a
lot to do with who's driving the car
because as the writer of the book it's
weird you don't really drive it because
it's such a visual medium you know
that's why I like when you look at a
co-creation credit
it's a writer and an artist because
somebody has to conceive in the ship
yeah somebody I could sit there and
describe it till I'm blue in the face
but somebody's literally gonna have to
be like all right this is what that
moment looks like in the real world you
know if the real world was 2-dimensional
pretty fascinating [ __ ] process and
my favorite thing to do when writing
comics is to remove words from panels
that don't need them anymore
even playing them like you write stuff
on the page and you think the dialogue
is necessary and you think that all this
is required to make the story make sense
and then an artist does when an artist
does which is I told your story for you
I'm your cinematographer I've figured
out the best angles I figured out how to
convey emotion without words and my job
is then to pull out the words I don't
need like too much words like this
picture does it pictures better than my
words [ __ ] me
little corner the soft knee approach to
write it you [ __ ] me I'm suck at this
I am I turn in my scripts right after
Christmas and I think it comes out at
some point next year as soon as marks
run is done I'll let you know when
that's happening but uh but yeah I had a
little bit of comic-book news of my own
that I was actually involved in this
week now let's dive down the rabbit hole
of the news that you prepared for us
this evening my good friend the real
news I mean I didn't like report the
news I just went to the internet and
copied and pasted the news found some
news yes reporting journalism account
search man a box office this weekend
over the Thanksgiving weekend okay
Justice League is holding okay not
amazingly well but pretty good movie
though it was Nicole Coco from Pixar
okay yes I did how is it it's beautiful
it'll make you [ __ ] cry like you
won't believe
really I know that's a low bar to to get
over but it's a it's a story that's
ultimately about art it's about the
creation of art and whether or not you
can compromise your desire to create art
based on obligations to family I'm ready
to cry right now
it's it's yeah and and it's all about
this kid who really wants to be a
musician but his family for generations
has outlawed music like [ __ ]
Footloose town you can't dance you can't
have anything to do with music and
ultimately he's desperate to become a
musician he discovers that maybe one of
his distant relatives was the most
famous musician in all of Mexico he goes
to steal his guitar some can perform in
the town square and somehow ends up
crossed over between the land of the
living to the land of the dead so the
entire second act of the movie takes
place in the land of the dead Dia de los
Muertos and it's just beautiful and
looks so lovely and it's all about the
ancestors you've left behind and the
ancestors you're not in contact with you
don't have a connection to and realizing
that the people you thought you knew you
had no idea what they were actually
about
and it's like by the time you get to the
end of this thing and I'm not gonna
spoil any more than that but just
[ __ ] tears from here to eternity just
all of the [ __ ] everything everything
it's got this amazing second act twist
that you don't see coming and by the
time you get to the end and and you
realize that it's not only about making
art it's not only about obligation to
family it's about finding the compromise
between the two and and art is often
compromised especially mass art the art
that we make it's never everything you
want it to be it's alright I got to make
this concession to get that thing I've
got I've got to write this because the
artist wants to draw it I've got it I
know the actor will do better with this
than that like it's compromised it's all
compromised but it's with a vision and
it's it's just beautiful beautiful I
didn't expect to be as taken by it as I
was
you sold the ticket I'm gonna go now you
should beware though there is in front
of cocoa and about this is on the
internet a 22-minute quote unquote short
for frozen now you would imagine this
would be popular a popular idea with
kids because everyone [ __ ] loves that
let it go [ __ ] they yeah I mean what a
lot of people showed up to see cocoa and
were baffled by the fact that they were
seeing frozen will apparently like ten
minutes into it people started coming
out be like are you showing the wrong
[ __ ] movie does that don't look like
the land of the dead you know
and like Pixar is and and Warner and and
Disney Animation are great the shorts
are awesome they always do this little
like four or five six minute little
keyword is short of lovely they did a
full on [ __ ] television Christmas
special in front of Coco I'm like if I
brought a kid who was like I want to see
Coco and had to make them sit through
half an hour of [ __ ] Elsa and Anna
and Olaf the [ __ ] dumbass mule snow
thing I guess you know like that's a lot
of popcorn I'm feeding this kid to keep
him happy or leaving did you so what was
your scenario did you I went just with
my wife you know the two grown-ups in
the theater for the parents and children
and and didn't have to leave but I kept
wondering like I'm gonna see this on
Disney Channel like next year for free
why don't I pay them money for this what
did you pay the money for it it's just a
part of the money you paid to see Koko
theoretically through the amount of
screen time why did they do it why make
it that long why because it's I'm
positive it's gonna be on TV next year
for Christmas really yeah I mean 20 22
minutes that's built-in for commercials
Wow
back to our Christmas special yeah it
sounds way dirtier than I meant it but
at the same time I would like to see
that so yes if you're going to go see it
just beware you might want to show up
like 20 minutes late people are people
are upset about it I'm talking about
it's like don't make me sit through a
whole [ __ ] show that movie I don't
need more in that movie you think Disney
thought like although [ __ ] love it
there yeah free thing highest-grossing
animated movie of all time how do you
not want more this but not at all not so
much I think it has more to do with what
you said though it's like he meant like
if you were taking a kid to see kids
movie and that movie was like you'd get
a bunch of trailers it's already about
20 minutes longer than the experience
needs to be then you tack on another
[ __ ] short that's not really a short
and how do you explain that to a child
you're like it's a sure they're like 1/8
short at all that's no man yeah so just
FYI that's the deal
if you want to see more it's [ __ ]
singing and dancing with snowmen and and
mooses and Vikings or whatever then hey
by all means
Olaf some magical winter adventure is
for you but if not this is [ __ ] skip
on past the concession stand
all right so cocoa made how much cocoa
made 71 million dollars over the
five-day weekend that's big and and
Justice League made fifty fifty nine
point six you know the only the only
real note of comparison for Justice
League's grosses are that in the same
ten days from release to now Justice
League made 171 million dollars while
Wonder Woman made 206 million dollars
which is the difference of 45 million 35
35 million my math is off so okay well I
mean it's not like it's that far off and
yet but at the same time
yeah I can at first I'm like wow that's
[ __ ] close but the idea it was
Justice League was supposed to be bigger
than Jesus Christ and we clearly saw
that didn't happen so you know I think
they were hoping to get close but at the
same time Wonder Woman was a phenomenon
that they weren't prepared for so I
think it may be an unfair box-office
comparison I'm not I'm not sure what to
do with that one
except I mean the real story is that
it's not the number one movie like two
weeks in a row and there is a drop it's
not precipitous but it's pretty large
now it'll seems like it all it did well
worldwide right domestically is only
where it's using its putting its ad 481
million dollars worldwide sounds like a
lot of money to me it's not bad I mean
but they said it needs to make 700
worldwide for it to be a profitable
movie for them which sounds like they
make will they get there if they're at
4:59 I think they'll get to 700 but
again the comparison is with Avengers
which made 1.3 billion dollars
how much yeah that didn't cost Batman V
Superman made nine hundred and something
million dollars but yeah it is going to
fall short of almost every other
comparison in its league did you see the
picture of Joe Manganiello but right yes
he married Sofia Vergara the he's
married to Sofia Vergara is that I think
of him as the dude for the Wolfman from
from True Blood but you reduced him to
somebody's husband that's interesting in
any event he played Deathstroke the
Terminator
Slade Wilson in the very last and best
maybe best scene of the Justice League
movie like where you really only [ __ ]
they're setting us up for what could be
well the joke that Luther made was like
don't we deserve a league of our own
which language what love wise would lead
you to believe in Justice League but
there's a picture of that guy Jo
standing next to a board that says
Legion of Doom like a title treatment
did was that real did that happen or is
that an Internet hoax do you know I
don't know
I don't know I know they released a
still from the movie but I don't know if
that was an unadulterated still but I
want a [ __ ] Legion of Doom oh god I
didn't yes I want that movie better now
that would movie would make so much
[ __ ] money
if you just go goofy with people in
outfits like kind of like that last
post-credit scene just add [ __ ] ten
more and it don't have to be Batman it
could be members Lee could just be
[ __ ] cyborg for all I give a [ __ ] but
show me all those villains and call the
Legion of Doom I promise you you will
make a lot of [ __ ] loot right yes did
you or is that just like my childhood
talking because they have a hard time
making all the with just slate
I don't know if the Legion of Doom is
gonna push him over the top but I think
going weird and doing [ __ ] like that
might be more the move I think so I
think so there's also a tweet that went
out over the weekend at David Ayer was
answering questions about his new movie
Brite and somebody asked him that's the
max landis grass the max landis Will
Smith Magic cops in LA stuff yeah it
looks like a cross between the real
world and works yeah he's an orc cop or
something orcs in the hood working day
but he's he mentioned he sort of came
clean and said you know I think we made
a mistake with Suicide Squad The Joker
should have been the villain
yeah I mean I think we all felt that way
we didn't know really who that I mean
the enchantress wound up being the
villain kinda hang there I just watched
her was her name Cara Delevingne I think
she's a I think she's gonna be I think
she's good actors I think she keeps
getting some roles that don't let her be
the actress she could be but I just I
was sitting home before I came here
watching valerian yeah and she's like
she's really great in it like charming
as [ __ ] like movie star charming and
wonderful but you know the the Suicide
Squad movie like drastically reduced her
role and didn't really let her show her
chops off but I look forward to watching
the rest of Lehren she's really really
good in it
that being said I'm sorry Suicide Squad
Schwab the tangential bad guy and David
Ayer yes that's right she was the
technically the bad guy but unwilling
Joker would have made a lot more sense
if the mission was get the [ __ ] Joker
we're just gonna send the Suicide Squad
after the Joker I think that's the movie
where we're all hoping for yes and I was
torn between having to do this and I
worked to save puddin a good double
agent yeah so he agrees he does I like
him he's a really nice guy I think he's
a talented filmmaker too that movie's
little confused but entertaining to say
the least but he I'm looking forward to
watching bright when's that happen soon
I think in the month or so free on
Netflix yep so I can watch it on my
[ __ ] nice not like a giseng watchin
anywhere I guess most people watching on
the laptop so I just carry my phone
around like this I while I was watching
The Runaways I was walking the dog in
the hill watching the third episode know
I was like this is the [ __ ] way to do
it don't even feel like a workout
anymore it's a little life hack for it
what do you got next uh Star Wars the
last Jedi is tracking forward while
we're in box-office land 200 million
dollars plus opening sounds big yeah
that is big that is big
what's the biggest opening weekend of
all time at this point
umm-hmm was it force awakens force
awakens 248 million dollars opening week
so they're saying this is going to do
two hundred which to be fair like that's
that would be expected force awakens was
a cultural phenomenon of like can
you believe they're doing this yet again
and they're bringing back your heroes
holy [ __ ] they killed Han Solo spoilers
this one is more of like alright the
sagas goin this one's gonna like you'll
lose a percentage of that the whole
world's gotta go cuz it's just the thing
to do on this movie whether this movie
is better than the last movie or not
there's gonna be a bit of a fall-off but
200 million is [ __ ] not bad not at all
that's pretty sweet and I think that
movie is gonna make I don't know if
it'll do as high as force awakens but I
think it's a secret weapon there's some
[ __ ] we don't know about this movie I
think that's gonna push it over the top
I mean is most of what we don't know
about this movie they've been very
careful in the trailers and even the TV
stuff did not give too much away the
billboards are going up all over town
and I saw Carrie Fisher solo billboard
that made me roll it tear on Cahuenga on
my way here on my way back from here so
the outdoor advertising is beginning in
earnest the YouTube spots are like
happening like crazy every time I go to
watch a YouTube clip there's a Star Wars
commercial which thrills me but the same
time I'm like in this movie pre-sold
already like why would you especially
the internet crowd they don't have to be
reminded hey kids you ever hear Star
Wars like we're all lined up for it it's
like when you go into an IHOP and
there's pictures of Pancakes on the wall
it's like [ __ ] man I hop already
you do not have to get me in the door
he's already put up a picture of a
sunset [ __ ] yes yeah I wonder why do you
think they're just like look we got to
spend money on advertising why not throw
things yeah we got to in a million
dollars to spend on it just spend it see
I'm the guy that would be like just cut
that part of the budget like no [ __ ]
YouTube what are you crazy they're all
going put it on [ __ ] lifetime
put it on what else would you put it on
like put it on the Christian
Broadcasting Network give those [ __ ]
people man it's about an immaculate
conception anyway truly there's
something going on all right so that's
gonna be I'm gonna be part of that money
I have not gotten an invite to the
premiere but even if I did it's
happening when I go to Colorado
I think they invite me all the times
they know I'm not here usually around
this time how I go to the do of Colorado
tour and stuff so force awakens I
couldn't go that premiere even though it
literally happened at the Chinese
Theatre a block from my [ __ ] house
like I could have [ __ ] skateboarded
down the hill to that premiere or
without breaking a sweat
so I got to go to the rogue one one last
year but this year I don't think I'm
gonna be able to that was in May well
that wasn't a Christmas movie wasn't it
no there's a Christmas movie and then
why the [ __ ] were you not in Colorado he
just held it a little bit earlier so I
was able to go to that one but this one
I don't think I'm gonna be able to go to
doesn't matter they didn't invite me but
it happens on when I think it's the
ninth downtown LA allegedly
theoretically eight hey how do you know
Rison Intel he went to the rogue one one
I thought you guys look familiar
nice all right I switch from AT&T to
Verizon can I go also
No then why is the Knights gonna go way
differently I feel stuff trying to have
a three-way with the audience I've got
all this sugar and wine it is your
birthday it's my birthday [ __ ] nut
all right what happens next in the news
Jude Law is in negotiations to join
Captain Marvel this is very exciting
Jude Law's one of my favorite actors the
young Pope notwithstanding I haven't
seen it not that he's good or bad and
I've just every is a good in it [ __ ]
nuts is it crazy it's the kind of nuts
that only Italians can make which is
likewise Lama the god of nuts only
Italian skin a mark barnard it but it's
got some of that weird ass [ __ ] neo
surrealist [ __ ] like the young Pope is
talking to a llama it's a [ __ ] that
[ __ ] happens in this show that's too
smart for me ooh something's going on in
Los Angeles
that joke was haha
okay what's he gonna play they have not
revealed what do you think he'll play I
think he plays will villain I think he
plays an alien villain I think he might
play promised that the villain would be
a well known Marvel villain
I mean they've already got a super
scroll they've already got Ben
Mendelsohn as the film's villain but I
think that if you're gonna do that the
scrolls there could be a few unless he
is it does Marvel still exist in that
timeline could he not be Marvel who
teaches Captain Marvel to be Captain
Marvel gives could be right he totally
could cuts the super heroic figure and
that is a part of the story interesting
that's a huge casting and that puts him
back in the Marvel Universe
with Robert Downey jr. mm-hmm Sherlock
and [ __ ] Watson and now the other
Sherlock and Watson are also in the
Marvel Universe so ones from the TV show
every Sherlock is here Wow I hope they
have scenes together they look like
they're friends yeah that'd be fun it's
not like a child here they're friends
but it must be part of it yeah I have a
Batman story today oh my god because you
just go down the gauntlet last week
saying that we have to cover more batman
for show that's called famine alabama
you're absolutely right which is the way
good sketch comedy was born the reason
that Bob and Doug McKenzie exists at all
on SCTV the old comedy show was because
Canadian content dictated you have to do
some Canadian content on the show there
has to be like 8 or 12 percent Canadian
content so they're like alright and they
created the most stereotypical Canadians
on the planet and they're like there it
is and it counts so we should have to do
a standard piece on Batman what do you
got according to one let me see child
development monthly pretending to be
Batman helped Keith helps keep kids on
task yeah
is this about child workers being
exploited no this is about a tool that
that a bunch of psychologists have used
to try and see what motivates kids to
work better and it turns out dressing a
kid up as Batman
helps him to be more attentive to his
task than being himself really yeah yeah
like if you can be Batman be Batman yeah
that's true it's words the live but and
yeah I mean some of the kids I'm gonna
I'm gonna read some psych [ __ ] here do
it hold on let's say 180 kids aged four
to six years old took place in some
basic psych tests assessing their mental
control memory and empathy the children
were encouraged to stay on task but they
were told that they could take a break
whenever they wanted to to go plan an
iPad some of the children were assigned
to self immersed condition which is a
control group which it just means that
they're being themselves and they're
gonna ask themselves this question am i
working hard other kids were asked to
reflect from a third-person perspective
saying is James working hard the rest of
the kids were in the Batman condition oh
my this sounds cruel the Skinner box
[ __ ] man they're like let's [ __ ] with
kids you're Batman you're Batman you're
not you'll never be you just gotta be
you [ __ ] and you talk about yourself
like you're that guy now everybody go
the kids in the Batman condition were
asked to imagine they were Batman and as
themselves over the course of their task
is Batman working hard children the last
condition were given relevant answers
that question is always [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
yeah he's always vigilant he's always
working and so the kids who were Batman
got Batman capes of course across age
groups and apparently unrelated to their
personal scores on mental control memory
or empathy we were way across age groups
we could have been involved in this
chair we could have got capes and I
could have somebody finally go like you
are Batman 4 to 6 years old no sorry the
kids who were dressed as Batman spent
the most time on their tasks the
children in the as themselves spent the
least time and those in the third like a
third person spent
in the middle this suggests the results
suggest that pretending to be a popular
fictional character helps young children
to resist distraction at least compared
to the other conditions use the
experiment Wow
I mean I you know what I'm gonna go for
that it's there's no I mean the the idea
is to follow up this study in 20 years
as well and be like what happened to you
and he's like I still think I'm Batman
mugger jumping off roofs in jail like
that but that being said in the present
with what we know I believe that it's
you know they may what does it fake it
until you can make it totally like if it
helped whatever helps you do the task
whatever helps you visualize and stuff
like that as long as it doesn't hurt
people as long as is it going to mania
or psychosis if it helps you to believe
that you're Batman and that makes your
work harder [ __ ] whatever it's a it's
dressing for success as long as that
success is not punching people in the
face asking it's true it's weird like
the thing that Batman is probably most
known for at least cinematically is
punching [ __ ] [ __ ] in the face and
they're like kids you're Batman you know
did you did you catch that SNL sketch a
couple weeks ago chance the rapper was
the host yes
looks like the Bruce Wayne hosting is
charity ball and like hey I know Batman
really you gotta tell him to talk you
can't come breaking people's jaws
everybody who came in was like yeah I'll
talk about Batman yeah man stop that
[ __ ]
everybody's black like why you gotta
break my jaw I'm just going to my own
trunk it was really great sketch all
right so wait what that's uh how do we
put this into effect in our own lives
you think yeah I'm you know we're too
old to be wearing capes but is this
something for one to adopt I mean
haven't they just been talking about
this on like the last few episodes of
Walking Dead there's some really nice
monologues about [ __ ] faking it until
you can make it King Ezekiel spoilers
not a real king as finally he's talking
about that and talking about how he just
became there's one of the episodes of
the the SHA nominee people still watch
Walking Dead it's got all the ratings so
a lot of people are but I still watch
the wall
that they had one of their absolute best
episodes couple weeks ago called some
guy which focused mostly on Ezekiel and
stuff powerful powerful [ __ ] where you
know he kind of his late Baroness to
tell the [ __ ] story of who he is like
why he is the guy with the tiger and
stuff like that and in that episode they
did as one of the best episodes they've
had done it's also one of the worst bend
over and [ __ ] take it
episodes they've ever done cuz they took
away a beloved character spoilers if you
don't follow the show tune out cover
your ears one two three they [ __ ]
killed the tiger Shiva the CGT tiger
that was Ezekiel's [ __ ] tiger she
came in to rescue him and it looked like
he was about to die he's bitching at his
buddy Jerry Jerry's like get behind me
my king and he's like I'm not your king
and he just starts breaking down and
he's just like I'm just some guy some
guy who found a tiger and then the
[ __ ] tiger it's so beautiful dude I'm
gonna cry talking about tiger CG Tiger
comes out of nowhere [ __ ] takes like
there's a bunch of zombies and this
nuclear swamp that's coming at them and
[ __ ] toxic swamp and he takes one of the
zombies it just pitches it then all the
zombies come at them and stuff and
you're like no no there's no way they're
gonna [ __ ] don't do this to me don't
Old Yeller that [ __ ] cat man like
I've invested a lot of time in the CGI
cat and they [ __ ] let her die dude
and like you know he's going crazy he's
like we got a helper and like we can't
and you hear the noises of her [ __ ]
dying and she sacrificed herself so they
lost so much of the [ __ ] magic it
must be a part of the storyline and [ __ ]
because like part of the kingdom which
they've law everybody's been wiped down
so part of the the specialness of the
kingdom was Ezekiel having that [ __ ]
tiger and how exotic it was and strange
it just provided you with hope they
they've they killed that hope now I know
it's like you know the but the budget
Department must feel like thank God that
was the most expensive [ __ ] effect on
the planet creating a whole Tiger but oh
it was tough to watch it go it was one
of the best and worst episodes to watch
now can you have a zombie tiger I
wondered if they were gonna go that way
but generally when [ __ ] come in and
go crazy like when the zombies feed on a
horse or whatever they don't turn them
into zombie I didn't think that I
wondered I was like I think in a game of
Thrones this [ __ ]
and Ezekiel is gonna have to fight a
[ __ ] zombie tiger because that'd be
double heartbreaking but I don't think
they're going that route but you know
[ __ ] I thought Glenn was dead and
then the dumpster so you know you never
know what they're gonna do on that
[ __ ] show they did just announce I
was on talking dead last night and
Melissa McBride was on and avi last name
escapes me he's the guy whose plays
plays Sadiq the new character they just
added avi Nash they would announced
they're the few weeks ago there were I
guess it khan maybe the new york on one
of the cons they announced that the two
shows Walking Dead and fear The Walking
Dead would cross over they would have a
character go from one to the other they
kept as a surprise they finally
announced that last night on the talking
dead and it is Morgan yeah Lenny James's
car Lenny James's character Morgan and
so the idea I think on the show was just
to be like and they told us in advance
so like try to avoid the questions like
you know don't start speculating what
the storylines gonna be because like
that would frustrate the writers because
what if you get it right and [ __ ] like
that so we weren't gonna like go deep on
that topic or anything like that and I
think letting James just kind of outed a
bunch of [ __ ] by accident like he got on
the talking dead was just like you know
I've said I'm in Austin or start fear
The Walking Dead tomorrow I've said
goodbye to the cast and crew and and
Melissa was getting emotional like kind
of welling up and stuff and it seemed to
indicate like some dire consequences for
Morgan but then Morgan will live again
in a show a different show but at the
same time that show happens before the
show so it'll be Morgan's secret origin
stuff now that's not to say that the
character will definitely die on The
Walking Dead but it felt kind of like
they were saying goodbye last night
unintentionally and maybe he's just
being an actor and kind of mislead in
the audience who knows but it it's I
guess some cats on line were not happy
with the choice of character everyone
thought it was going to be Abraham who
was from Texas fear the walking dead
happens in Texas that Abraham character
of course
was his name Michael Cudlitz I believe
he's the guy who got killed by negan so
this has been a cool opportunity to
bring him back before he met Rosita or
maybe right when he meets Rosita who
knows but instead they're going with
Morgan thoughts you're not a big walking
dead guy anymore I haven't watched it in
four years oh [ __ ] so half these [ __ ]
people are you talking about really lost
Jay I gave up halfway through the
governor which I was a tough slog yeah I
feel like too much of this show was a
tough slog you know I mean and right
from the [ __ ] farmhouse I'm like why
are we still have the goddamn farmhouse
to this farmhouse I don't need a
farmhouse I'm like farms and so I just
after a while it was what I moved to
like when I moved from from New Jersey
to California and I got here and I
didn't have a DVR and that was the oh
well [ __ ] I guess I'm not watching The
Walking Dead anymore and I kind of
didn't miss it I kind of didn't miss it
I tuned back in for the negan premiere
just cuz I wanted to see what that was
right and then realize it was so
punishingly bleak and brutal that I was
not getting any enjoyment out of
watching The Walking Dead you think they
should bring in Joss Whedon the light
and [ __ ] up we're gonna have discussions
george RR martin would lighten that [ __ ]
up and he kills [ __ ] like
tomorrow
well it's they got some good stuff going
on in that episode and that was the big
news of that came out of there I look
forward to seeing I want to see how they
work him in I guess that means you're
gonna see Morgan and his family may see
his wife may see you know its kid we met
his kid way back in the beginning so I'm
interesting cool thing to do over there
finally cross those things over I mean
if you have a universe [ __ ] use the
universe you know expand it should what
else we got Deniz hit my friend that's
the news rabbit that's the news all
right let me see what else I got on the
agenda we got a guest we do absolutely
man right now ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna bring out a gentleman he's a funny
gentleman [ __ ] we're gonna - he's gonna
tell us a story about what he's doing
over here
ramas you hear come on out man everyone
give it up for rama sh
Ranga Nathan
[Applause]
hello hello how are you jump into the
center hello hello thank you now ramas
you do comedy this is Mark II met mark
yes yes hey these are all serious I'm
sorry to interrupt your enjoyment thank
you thank you
now your comedian I am yeah
here there everywhere just in the UK up
to this point so I've been doing
stand-up in in the UK for about six
seven years and then I've always loved
American stand-up and my American comedy
and so I decided to sort of suck it off
and then you can come over here and say
I would get on I heard you guys are
really welcoming immigrants at this
moment in time yes good time yeah yeah
what would be a good time to come over
and say okay so especially brown ones me
ticking all the boxes man properly
smashing I've got the look that they're
after and everything man so I'm excited
but actually I was interested in what
you were so mark early about your um
about you giving up your career to go
into something completely different
because I I was a teacher before I was a
stand-up in fact really where do you I
was teaching like a maths high school we
don't call it a high school but we so I
was teaching maths and then I gave up
gave that up to do stand-up and then
I've sort of come over here to sort of
roll the dice again Janine so yeah we're
sort of quite inspiring here you talk
about that but I mean you've succeeded
I've done nothing so inspired me to take
a risk so yeah cuz of my family over
here and everything in fact we just
watched Coco this weekend in the cinema
how did how did it play for you well one
of my sons we encourage our children to
sort of much I've got three boys 86 and
86 and three and we encourage their
right to protest and one of them was
protesting being made to watch Coco meal
before I said you've got to come with us
because it's family time I said but if
you want to carry on an object you can
object and so for the duration of the
film he sat facing away from the screen
with his hands over his ears for the
entire duration a conscientious objector
yeah yeah he was properly like a
gangster I don't know what statement he
was making he had he he enjoyed up he
loved all the Toy Story so I don't know
where the militancy started I mean but
knows about John Lasseter yeah well I
think it's a strong he just said to me
I'm not having it dad I mean like John
NASA that's where I draw the line so I'm
not gonna watch anything anymore Jane
but it's a weird one I do want to talk
about this
by the way Coco is incredible like I
thought it was a return to form
I picked circle that means slightly I
think they've been slightly off but like
this is amazing
I do want to talk about that [ __ ]
unacceptable frozen react
eh [ __ ] freeze that is I am more
opposed to that short than I am racism
it is a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] disgrace
that short right it's 22 minutes for a
star secondly I'm gonna do some spoiler
as it it is a piece of [ __ ] right even
even if you buy into the frozen world
and listen time to spoiler alert if
you're if you're looking forward and
excited to watch it what the [ __ ] you do
with your life but I am doing a spoiler
alert now right they the set up for that
god damn short right sure it's not sure
long long as [ __ ] that's why they should
call as you call it before you see
Khokar you're about to watch it long as
[ __ ] alright so anyway
thus out for this is it's Christmas time
right fine I'm on board with that so far
it's Christmas time they ring a bell to
signify the start of the holidays right
and then the two girls was Elsa and Anna
and Anna right they they let the bell
rings and then everybody leaves the
court that the the palace area or
whatever to go off and do they do their
thing and then they go you what you want
to come in we're having a party inside
we're coming with every part and they go
no we've got stuff to do are you are you
[ __ ] me because I'm pretty sure the
entire town gathered to watch you wring
a [ __ ] Bell and you're inviting them
into the palace and
not coming in and that's the whole setup
they're lonely because people won't come
it sorry mate have you seen Twitter
today people are losing their [ __ ] about
one of the royal family getting engaged
so if you get invited into the house I
think you're gonna go mate I mean the
whole premise is [ __ ]
I honestly III do think people should
protest it and I'm encouraging you to
protest it for the 22 long minutes it's
on before Coco it is it is as [ __ ] as
Coco is wonderful so there you go now in
your journey over here yeah what's going
on
well so basically I am I
I've come over here and I wanted to give
myself a target like a gold do you know
I mean like something to sort of measure
myself against because I thought it's
very difficult in comedy it's very
difficult to know there's no there's no
moment where you think I've done it so
like I'm trying to justify to my wife
and kids me coming over here and doing
this so what I decided to do is I
decided to do like a big symbol of my
journey and what I did is I I spent a
lot of money and I booked the Greek
Theatre right really yeah yeah yeah for
the 21st of December now for those
unfamiliar out here in Los Angeles the
Greek Theatre is an amphitheater is that
right that's correct so what I didn't
realize is part of the reason I think I
was allowed the booking is because it's
a 21st December and it's an outdoor
venue I don't think they had I don't
know that many people who like fighting
for that for that day so that was the
idea so I've sort of booked that and
then in my head I thought I'd gradually
week by week sort of making exciting
steps awards selling it out I don't want
to sort of I mean I don't want to [ __ ]
on your inspiring story mark but
currently the venue has a capacity of
five thousand nine hundred I have sold a
hundred and thirty tickets so so if
anybody here has got five thousand
friends that was really that would
really help me out
what I've also found out is is all of
the British expats that might have
wanted to come and see me they go home
for Christmas
so they won't even be in LA so so it's a
difficult one yet mean but so what I'm
saying is help me because because the
love of my children depends very much on
this show gaming world yeah that means
so so that's the situation basis when is
the show 21st of December 21st of
December at Woking they give tickets
they can get tickets from my website
Ranma shrenger Nathan calm we like to
sort of make it a test but we could do
an easy website but I want to know that
you really want the [ __ ] tickets I
mean so spell my name and look it up or
you can go to the Greek website or
Ticketmaster how long is your show my
show word depends how many people turn
out it was a hundred and thirty people
it will be a five-minute apology and
then they will just leave but it's about
I don't know it we'll see how it goes 60
70 minutes no we'll just see
so anybody are they gonna shoot it no
well I don't even that carrot to dangle
like hey you could be the true fear is
the truth is I am like my journey
towards that is being documented so you
will be yeah you could be filmed but I
don't think it like if seven people turn
up I will tell them to turn the [ __ ]
camera I'm not having the show covered
jo means so so there you go that's the
situation you know it's nobody will know
as long as the camera points at this
stage that's sure yeah but there's only
so much you can pretend that you're
killing it right but yeah I played at
one time I was supposed to play in a
room at the San Diego Comic Con the Hall
H and it seats what six thousand yeah
and then like right before my show like
JJ Abrams to the Star Wars panel and
then they took the entire audience out
to see a free concert where they gave
out plastic lightsabers and [ __ ]
so the entire [ __ ] place emptied and
I was like what do we do and they're
like there's some people in line still
outside and look how
couple hundred and I'm like this is a
six thousand seat room it's gonna look
like a hotdog in a [ __ ] hallway man
so I was a moment where I was like let's
cancel the show even I would rather go
walk and watch the Star Wars concert
I've heard Kevin Smith talked before
[ __ ] this guy but they eventually found
like there was two thousand people and
stuff at two thousand and six thousand
cedar looks [ __ ] hardcore not as bad
as 150 and a five thousand cedar I was
trying to help I've moderated panels at
comic conventions where there were more
people on the dais than in the audience
that's true so it's like hey you guys
could just sit up here we got better
seats yeah let's have a good
conversation yeah I feel worse thank you
really trying about alright man so
everyone here tonight and everyone who
watched at home or listens at home they
got it hopefully if you're in the Los
Angeles area man let's beef those
members yes please yeah god help me
please because my marriage is on a knife
edge thank you very much even at four
hours everybody awesome oh my god that
was tremendous and that was [ __ ]
worth it to hear the review alone I mean
it checks out it really does you know I
like the show is like free and easy
enough who I can now someone way funnier
than we should do more of that does this
for a living
okay we've come to the part of the show
that's so [ __ ] fun folks this is the
QA part of fat man on Batman this is
where
we turn to you the audience to talk
about some [ __ ] that you want to talk
about we again have a selection of gifts
to give to the people that get to ask
this [ __ ] is mine questions are you
taking that
I'm taking my wine we've got as we have
the previous few episodes Deacon is here
in the audience
Deacon works at 4dx which is Deacon for
the last few weeks man 40x has given us
tickets to give out if you've never seen
a movie in 40x there's three places I
know of right now that you can go up
like in New York Los Angeles and Chicago
that I'm sure there are more places
opening and stuff if you haven't seen a
moving 40x like treat yourself I'm gonna
go see [ __ ] last Jedi on 40 X because
the chairs move with the movie the chair
is constantly in motion that you're
sitting in when it snows in the movie it
snows in the [ __ ] theater when you
went a motorcycle goes by you smell the
burnt rubber because it shoots sense at
you all the time if somebody farts you
smell no they haven't gotten that far
yet but one day they might but the 40x
experience with the chair moving when
you're watching the crawl of a Star Wars
movie the chair goes back with the crawl
that's [ __ ] intense so 40 X is a
great experience and there it's here at
LA Live I think that's where they have
it here last week we we gave out how
many sets tickets we give out ten how
many do we have has time - same thing
Deacon you there Bueller deacons like
[ __ ] your show all right here we go
we've got one two three four five so
yeah ten tickets - said nobody wants to
take a single ticket you want to be able
to go - nobody it's like 40x experience
literally this is the one theater you
can go to by yourself because it is kind
of like your enclosed in this chair but
it's also cool to have somebody
afterwards be like wasn't that [ __ ]
amazing did you feel the rain on your
face they [ __ ] snowed right into my
[ __ ] face so we've got that as
tickets and we've also got tickets here
man how many we get anybody know 11
tickets from from
please is this from you so we've got
right across the street is this cross
street right or near by yeah it's down
the block a bit like one of the things
that I went to when I first came out to
Los Angeles as a little boy was a
Ripley's Believe It or Not auto is it
still called the auditorium where they
call it is the auditorium we went and
did a piece on The Tonight Show there
years ago
it's an historic part of Hollywood
Boulevard it's very nearby and we've got
13 tickets 11 tickets to give I see
three there's three there may be the
rest are in the bag or something like
that yeah they fell them maybe they fell
that yeah I'm sorry they're falling over
the bag all right so 11 [ __ ] tickets
to the auditorium did you give us pens
too and you get pens as well
arrey they write what color what's your
name Corey give it up for Corey
everybody we're getting so many [ __ ]
prizes to give out it's like it's
competing with one of my true passions
about doing this show is collecting all
the crap that I can't give away and
bring it here and giving them out as
prizes and [ __ ] like that so I've also
got some [ __ ] whoever asks the question
gets to come up and pick we got a Batman
versus two-face blue right here I just
got a loot crate open today and I had a
Buffy the Vampire Slayer statue in it
there's a Jason Voorhees hockey mask and
we've got 40 X tickets and we've got
Ripley's Believe It or Not tickets do
you care if we package them together put
them together
fantastic so we'll still innocent - I
think okay let's while we're chitchat
let's do one - per each and put those
together okay JC has a microphone that
he's going to run around with so people
at home can actually hear the questions
as well JC I leave it to you to pick
whoever you want remember the questions
got to be good like if you ask it like
hey man when's Jay and Silent Bob gonna
return you don't win anything
the questions should be show relevant of
course and they should but you know
genre relevant and whatnot and they
should address both of us nobody wants
to stand around while one guy answers
questions and stuff so the best
questions get it man now that we got
cool [ __ ] prizes at play everybody's
got to lift up their [ __ ] a-game
lifts all boats yes yes absolutely true
the the the more creative the ver
answers that come from the questions the
better chance you get at winning some
[ __ ]
JC pick where we're going he can't win
tickets to his own [ __ ] thing it's
okay I've been holding on to this for
three weeks
Alex and Kara mark I want you to write
me a story for young Alex and Kara from
Supergirl the episode like immediately I
was like oh my god Kevin yoga hosers
Alex and Kara this has to happen ask
Marc what you do with this so it's not
creepy Alex and Peres refers to
Supergirl yes the Supergirl episodes
with young Alex and young which is
amazing for those that don't follow the
world of Supergirl they recently did a
great episode the episode right after
mine was the episode where they went
back to Midvale and they did a story
about the young versions of Alex who's
played by Kyle early that's Alex Danvers
on Supergirl that Supergirl sister and
Cara who is also Supergirl on the show
played by Melissa Benoist so or Benoist
I heard them say Benoist on the Kids
Choice Awards I had a long conversation
with her about it once where I was like
I'd say Benoit you know and she's like
we used to but it has a different
connotation to some people and so now we
go Benowitz I say because of the balls
yeah totally I didn't think that need
explaining but thank you very much
but mostly adults got that one but
you're like that's balls kids balls okay
so that episode was charming his [ __ ]
because a it allowed you to go into the
kids history and be the they found kids
to play the kids that were pretty close
the girl who played to Kyler was like
spot-on
she really studied here and stuff so
it's a incredibly charming story I'll
spoil it if you're not watching
Supergirl this year it's really [ __ ]
good
like they're they're doing really great
stories and the episode they just did
last week introduced Legion of
super-heroes
so ma Nell wakes up and Saturn girl
wakes up and [ __ ] and you're like oh my
god we're getting there next up
brainiacs gonna show up Brainiac 5 not
Brainiac Brainiac legion flight ring
czar gonna be in play like it's it's
[ __ ] han prior to this they've been
telling a pretty like naturalistic a
real-life story and stuff in some
sections this story they talk about they
you know they go back to Midvale like
hang out with their mom and kind of
convalesce after Alex broke up with
Maggie Sawyer her love they were gonna
get married but instead they wound up
splitting up over a difference in
wanting to have children or not so they
go home to spend time with mom and then
they kind of pick her because they're
both in weird places and then go to
sleep as their adult selves and wake up
as the kids selves and they tell the
story of how the sisters first became
friends so it's a really charming story
about how she's like I don't want this
[ __ ] strange girl at our house and
blah blah blah
having to put up with her and people at
school like not like her and like her
sister and stuff then there's a kid that
a geeky kid with the telescope that Cara
hangs out with and he's the nerdy kid
but like he's nice to her and she like
that he winds up getting killed and so
if the episode becomes like the two
Danvers sisters cuz they both knew him
trying to figure out who killed Kenny
you know oh my god who killed him and so
it's the South Park East episode they've
ever done so they they
there's a bunch of turns and twists
there's an early appearance at one point
by like an early d EO agent that kind of
looks like Cara's mother who was played
at this season by the lady who played
Lois Lane I think in Smallville they had
to switch moms and stuff so at first
they're getting that bite of the Apple
were you know she's like mom and then
she doesn't look good she's not her mom
and so and so you're like oh I see why
they did that but then there's a PS to
that scene where the DOJ agent is like
you can't ever use your powers again
like you know you can't do that while
you're here and she's like I won't and
the DOJ agent leaves and it's Jean Jones
like him right away get choked up you're
like oh my god he was looking after I
mean they were kids
their relationship is incredibly [ __ ]
special in the show so ultimately and
this is where I'm gonna well up
ultimately they solve the murder of the
kid and who kills the kid is kind of
unimportant but what they find out is
like he was friends with car and they
had a moment where they could have
kissed but she felt kind of shy and it
didn't wind up happening as they're
going through his laptop they find an
image on his laptop that came from his
telescope and it's I'm gonna cry it's an
image of her flying he knew who she was
and he never told anybody such a [ __ ]
special story incredibly well done so
the question has to do with shouldn't
they continue that at least in the world
of comics keep it going right it's good
I think for them it honestly first place
in production it represented this lets
us give both Melissa and Kyler a couple
days off because we can hire people to
play them and [ __ ] like that but they've
lucked into something like you can keep
going with it they could do that
perennial a at least one a year or
something should it be in comics I'd go
for it I don't know what they're doing
with the character in comics now but you
know I would hope that there's some line
that hones close to the CW stuff I guess
not I'm not sure yeah it's a really
wonderful episode that they did and then
last week's episode was like intense and
they're building toward rain the
character Sam just figured out you know
she built intentionally built the
fortress of sanctuary which is like rain
you know supergirls version of the
fortress of solitude it's it's is really
lighten up man that show is wonderful
but the question he's obviously
completely unfamiliar with it it does
that answer the question
what would I do with it I think as I
would have before which is not including
old men I mean I mean it sounds like I
didn't see that other episode but it
sounds like a Nancy Drew episode
ultimately very much so incredibly so
yeah charming as [ __ ] as the two girls
go on you know a detective adventure
first unwillingly and then together and
that's how they bond and become sisters
for life and stuff really sweet I'm
telling you I've said it before I'll say
it again that show is so [ __ ] good
those people who are so good at their
jobs those actresses that they make me
feel like I've truly missed out in life
by not being a younger sister to an
older sister like I got an older sister
whenever I say she's like you had an
older sister I was like but in the
equation I was a boy like in this
fantasy equation I would be a girl like
it shows this incredible bond that
sisters have that made me go like [ __ ] I
missed out on something so anyway I mean
part of me wants to say you do like it'd
be kind of great if you did after
Supergirl runs its course this season
and they're gonna take the summer off
and see double you'll do whatever the
[ __ ] CW will do did you'd like an eighth
episode Danvers girls mystery show
whatever the [ __ ] maybe like race to
Witch Mountain II a little bit maybe
there's a maybe there's a like the
Danvers girls on the run maybe a John
Jones has to protect them from rogue
faction inside the de Oh something like
that but the two of them together
hunted by somebody and they've got to
both deal with each other because you
know you you you build a scenario in
which they are not on the best of terms
right well they've already done that you
can't ring that bell again now they're
still buddies yeah to put a wedge
between sisters don't you [ __ ] do it
they're important to me I feel like
puberty is always a great model for
conflict long as they don't fight over
some [ __ ] boy no nobody wants that
yeah I don't know but I think there's
absolutely a way to do that story you
know especially if you watch something
like Runaways and you see how they deal
with kids and young people and young
adults and the [ __ ] that that occupies
their minds that don't feel like they're
as big as the world ending but for them
the world is ending you know like that's
the thing for every kid that's what
Buffy did so well Buffy gave you
apocalypses every week that we're both
personal and supernatural and sometimes
the personal apocalypses feel felt
bigger they felt worse the oh my god I
nobody's gonna invite me to the dance
it's just as big a deal as I'm living on
a Hellmouth you know and it's figuring
out a way to navigate those two things
so that you can have all of the big
giant [ __ ] comic book awesome
but it's about this time in these girls
lives and what it means to both have
sisters to have an enemy sleeping in the
bedroom next to you who you might be
having conflict with what it means to
suddenly your body is doing different
[ __ ] I mean the x-men was nothing but a
metaphor for both puberty and and race
relations ultimately you know it's
there's so much in that [ __ ] stew
that you can just spin and ladle out and
absolutely have a great like eight or
ten episodes of awesome out of [ __ ] a
good answer all right man pick come pick
a prize come pick a prize where we going
next J see right there
I can totally sign that if you pitch it
up here with a marker but is that your
question I have a question but I would
appreciate that I could totally do both
think he brought a pop of me anyway so
Mike the question on the the question I
on top sorry yeah some people don't want
it on my face I'm like put it on my face
one of the things I appreciate about
both the the most is that how
interactive you are with the fans on
social media and telling stories about
your career and one of the stories of
Kevin that you told that always stuck
with me
with Superman and the spider and all
that I was wondering are there stories
from your you meetings you have with
with people asking the name name so
you're like you couldn't believe that
they thought a certain way that was just
so different than what the fans would
expect or just what they expected to be
a reasonable was just so outlandish yeah
I mean early early on when when the
first cycle of genius came out there's a
little bit of interest from Hollywood
people on it but again in case you don't
know what genius is about it's about a
17 year old black girl from South
Central who declares war against the
LAPD and succeeds four square blocks
from the Union again again that old
chestnut but but part of what makes that
book special is this best the
specificity of it is the where it's set
the when it's set the who would set
around and we'd have these meetings we
develop an executive like a listen we
love this book
but here's we want to do instead of Los
Angeles could it be like Long Beach and
instead of cops could they be like
private security and also could a
comment be heading towards the planet at
the same time we just need a reason why
we're better like earthquake any
post-apocalyptic and we would say hey
listen I would watch that season of 24
if you do that but you don't need this
book to do that
you know it's figuring out for at least
for us what made the things special to
begin with and then circling the wagons
around that and once you start monkeying
with the [ __ ] on the periphery fine I
don't care if she's 17 and she's 20 if
you're gonna get like find me a movie
star
I'll age it up to 30 I don't have to be
a teenager I get it
but so much of that is about context and
specificity and place and time and find
what makes it special and circle the
wagons around that you know and part of
what frustrates me when you know I go to
movies be they DC be they Marvel be
there whatever is here is the awesome
and you forgot what the awesome was you
know like here's what's awesome about
Superman the tragedy of Superman is that
he can't save everybody at once that he
can hear everything horrible that
happens in the world but could only save
one person at a time or maybe a building
of Ukrainians at a time what
ever but he hears everything and can't
save everybody
that's his tragedy it is not oh [ __ ] my
girlfriend got married to another guy
and had a kid now I'm a pervy stalker
hovering outside her window at night I
remember the Hat one that is not what
super minute Superman is not I could
save my dad but I won't because reasons
I don't know like remembering what these
characters are remembering what makes
them special and then just zeroing in on
that stuff and that's sometimes what I
feel like development people forget
because they have to justify their
decisions up a ladder and it's way
easier to say no than to say yes and
it's way easier to not take a risk or to
just [ __ ] its water something down
make it the most palatable version of
itself when sometimes it needs to be
Deadpool sometimes it needs to be
[ __ ] crazy and it needs to a lien ate
some people to thoroughly please others
that's smart
I let me see I don't know I don't have
it I mean I don't really deal in that
world that much anymore like it's I
don't have to sit with people that are
corporate and and have interest to
protect like I'm in my the walrus movie
phase of my career so I don't trip over
too much of that anymore the last thing
that was like and it wasn't even a big
deal it wasn't like I'm outraged but
somebody asked me hey man we got a toxic
avenger and we're gonna remake it do a
reboot and stuff and we think hey you're
from Jersey and you know I always kind
of Dig Dug what Lloyd Kaufman and the
Troma people do who was right in Jersey
I remember seeing him on the news all
the time they're like Hollywood motion
pictures in New Jersey right here at
Troma you know and and toxic avenger was
insanely well known so i always
respected the the Troma world and the
Toxie franchise so i was like i'll go
down the rabbit hole a little bit and
see what's what and we part ways
fundamentally on the budget because I
was just like part of the charm of the
toxic avenger is it's like [ __ ] made
for two nickels if you're gonna do it
again like don't spend a lot of money
but they were like no no it's a
thirty-five million dollar
and I was like it's a [ __ ] remake of
the toxic avenger like the guy in a tutu
with a bad makeup job like where are we
gonna spend all the money on coke like
so right then and there I was like I'm
not I'm clearly on the same page like I
in my head if I want to if I need to see
a toxic avenger remake it should be done
in the spirit of the original but
instead they were literally trying to
start a franchise like Marvel eyes it
and stuff like that and I'm like I don't
know if you guys saw that movie so I
just quietly stepped away like I
understand what they were going for but
like I would never want to see that
version of the movie it would be like
you know somebody doing a thirty five
million dollar version of clerks like
why would you bother
lasers man that's true we never had
lasers come on up and pick out a prize
well done man where we going next JC
wampa hat oh my god isn't wampa hat [ __ ]
I hope this show becomes more and more
like let's make a deal
like I want everybody in costumes old
enough signs of [ __ ] that's phenomenal
excellent job and you can't pull that
off in many bars you know what I'm
saying
very true you should be able to because
it's a genius conversation piece it says
so much about you without you saying a
[ __ ] word and it could draw people as
well to a lot of other people and you
know who are drunk in a bar they'd be
like what the [ __ ] going on
kill it with fire what happened but I
respect the [ __ ] out of that well thank
you on to your question so can you as
you ask just show us all sides and [ __ ]
I don't mean turn around but I do want
to oh my god that is [ __ ] phenomenal
did you where'd you get that uh so I was
at a Disneyland and it's this is
actually just a wampa like toboggan and
I was one boy and so I got tired of
carrying around so I'll put it on my
cowboy hat and got so popular walking
around Disneyland that I'm like this is
how I'm wearing my cowboy hat from now
on yeah it's a thing man you created a
thing like Michael Jackson with the one
glove
he's like wampa Nelson all right your
question my friend so me and my friends
used to argue about superheroes back in
the day when we were kids and so now I'm
gonna pass this Batman question on to
you since you're the fat man on Batman
I always argued that Batman actually
does have a superpower besides the fact
of you know him saying I'm rich lighting
the last movie right he actually is in
my opinion super will cuz there's no one
human being who can be that dedicated to
doing what he does and I just want to
get your all's take on that opinion I
would hands down I would agree with that
absolutely the part of the charm of the
character has always been not just like
hey it could be me because he doesn't
have [ __ ] quote-unquote super powers
and stuff and I could be like Batman as
long as I had a billion dollars and my
parents got [ __ ] killed so but beyond
that there's the relatable aspect of
like this is somebody who won't quit he
has a will of iron like one of the
things that will always carry with me to
my grave is like some throwaway internal
passage in a comic it may have been in
blind justice the Sam Hamm like three
issue series but he talked about only
needing three hours of sleep
he's like the human body only needs
three hours of sleep you know it
especially if you're driven in [ __ ] and
I remember taking that [ __ ] seriously
some [ __ ] I read in a comic book you
know and put it into effect in my life
and found that like you can't really
[ __ ] exist on three hours of sleep a
lot of naps but three hours of hardcore
[ __ ] sleep at night so yeah I mean
I've never had the iron will of a Batman
obviously I couldn't get past the
working out part but the character does
have an incredible will yeah and yes
that can be a superpower
I would agree with that mark I think
it's it's is will Plus mania you know
and I think athletes have incredible
will look again if you gonna be an
Olympic class athlete your life is Drive
and I get that but the the level to
which Bruce Wayne drives himself is not
rational by any stretch of the
imagination and so if you add crazy Plus
driven you get Batman and whether or not
that qualifies as superpower or just
again crazy pants
I that's four smarter people than I to
say but but yeah it's not just money
money is not what makes them special no
you know look I think that that I mean
year one shows you money's not what
makes him special what makes him special
is is the capacity to push through what
normal people should not be able to push
through
I like his version better the super will
you're like super well you have a super
[ __ ] crazy
isn't that crazy strong it can't like
you always get comfortable talking about
that could happen in the real world but
think about when you just brought the
athlete thing I never really thought
about that comparison people that are
like Olympians devote incredible amounts
of time their entire lives train for
like one very important race and stuff
in peak physical condition for that but
after that race they like kind of go to
a somewhat normal life in order to be
Batman you would have to be training for
the some an Olympian event every [ __ ]
day of your life while also going out at
night and brutally fighting crime with
your body like I don't give a [ __ ] if
you got a Batmobile or not I guess
that's just not really possible isn't it
I don't think that level of sustained
effort is possible you know like there's
it's like Grant Morrison's Batman Inc
was such an interesting idea because the
franchises franchise that's you know and
that and that's how the whole world is
like he was here he was here he was here
it's just like you keep people people
guessing
I remember watching Ninja Warrior like
really early on when it would be on like
g4 or something they would import it and
there was this one afloat Makoto Nagano
who is the closest I've ever seen
to Batman in that his body did whatever
he told it to and he never seemed to
break a sweat he never seemed to be out
of breath when the ferger's got a climb
a rope that's 50 feet I does it gets to
the top moves on to the next thing lift
this thing that's 100 pounds swing over
here climb is hold on with your [ __ ]
fingernails hang upside down all of this
[ __ ] never seemed like he was tired and
did it over and over and over again and
that's the closest I've ever seen to a
human being who was Batman
now that he doesn't compete anymore
because doing that at that level will
break your spirit and wreck your body
right but Batman like crazy goes a long
way Crazy's the fuel when food doesn't
do it there it is you one man grab some
tickets whatever you want where are we
going next
JC's got us on the other side hey how
you guys doing so good awesome I
actually have a question for both of you
more on the psychology portion of the
podcast that you mentioned about Batman
pretending to be Batman and how it
affects kids now I know we talked about
how that doesn't really draw really for
adults necessarily but what if it did
how would that be brought out what would
be some good ways to do that because I
find that you know we read these comics
and read these stories we watch these
movies and we feel better somehow and I
feel like the kids in some some small
way the reason why they were successful
at being on task was because they wanted
to be someone else and I feel like
that's almost innate in almost everybody
that we want to be someone else other
than ourselves so how do we channel that
so that we can actually stay on task or
complete task number one [ __ ] great
question number two you take
it sounds incredibly smart I think that
we all sort of do that anyway like what
do they say like dress for the job you
want not the job you have you know the
like actors whenever you talk to them
and say you know I didn't really feel a
character till I put on the the Wardrobe
until I got in the suit until I until I
I wore the the the arraignments of glory
you know like I think that that we are
very much
I guess propelled by the way we feel
about the way we look and I think that
there is a psychological twist that
happens no turn the other way but you're
you were there we go it was a solo show
for a minute there I was just drifting
but yeah like I think that that what we
wear helps determine how we treat the
world and how we treat ourselves in the
world so yeah I mean sometimes it's a
small thing sometimes it's a lucky charm
sometimes it's a uniform you have your
[ __ ] drift into the other direction
where do you want me to go the plant
dude I feel I own the space a little bit
you are you're taking a lot of things to
claim in the crease nobody think that
that's that's part of it is the am I
good you're good okay thanks just making
sure but yeah that that what we wear can
help determine the way we look on our
day if we look at ourselves in the
mirror like the way we look we act a
different way as true some of us believe
we're hockey players
[Applause]
you know and I and I think that there is
an end for some people like Einstein
only ever wore the same suit because he
didn't want to waste the brain space and
deciding what to wear every day and that
for him was the uniform and that uniform
he felt smart and that uniform he felt
like he could do almost anything because
even have to waste time thinking about
other [ __ ]
I think there's little ways that we can
use that that aren't quite as
magnificent as a kid dressed as Batman
or I also heard a story about this
little girl who was afraid to fly until
she put on like an Amelia Earhart outfit
like so she had the air goggles and the
[ __ ] leather hat and why would that
rock Rose less afraid to fly that's like
the most famous non flyer in history
[ __ ] it disappeared she flew off into
the sunset but yes she felt like if
anything went wrong with the plane that
she could maybe help and that let her
get on a flight that let her travel
across the ocean you know it's the
little things for adults I think it's it
is again the I feel a little bit better
about myself in these shoes or I really
like the cut of this suit and where hey
these jorts are awesome look at the room
I have in these jorts you know and
sometimes it's like hey if like if
you're losing weight and suddenly the
thing you wearing feels so that baggy
you feel a little bit better like you're
making progress you're doing something
it helps to to push you further down
that road to success I think it's for
adults it's the little things and if you
do enough little things it's I think it
can amount to something that's a theory
based on nothing more than an article I
read one time you want tickets hell yeah
you want to good oh yeah well done give
it up firm folks they want some chick
I smoked a bowl with me after the show
oh my god happy birthday on the 4th I
would love to say yes but I got to drive
after this and if I smoked a bowl before
I drove oh my god
free weed absolutely take more tickets
thank you
great question alright JC we're we're
gone has that been three or four four we
got hey that was two I just I just want
to say like the one thing I think
impresses me both impresses me the most
about both you guys is just the attitude
of like you don't wait for permission
just make something well in art not like
in life and [ __ ] like that oh absolutely
not referring to procreation no just
just you know whether it's the comic
books or clerks or this podcast just get
it done and however you can and get the
story out there and I'm making comic
books with my stories cuz I wanted to do
TV and I for years I was like but I have
to have an agent and it's like no I just
have to tell the story bang and one of
the things I'm running into is people
don't show up for work to do the art and
I was wondering how do you motivate
especially comic book artists to treat
it like a professional job and and
finish the work because I love these
stories and they're great and I not sure
I have the magical will of Batman to
just you know make everything happen
and what do I do that's my question
I mean I I always go to I you know they
say humans always err on the side of
what is easiest so in my world if that's
my equation I just go get a different
artist like it rather than try to like
hey man you know
bored it's like it's much easier to
start with somebody who's passionate
than to fire somebody's passion up if
they're not hitting the mark for you and
it's not just like they may have life
you know life gets in the way like I'm
doing all this other [ __ ] so I would err
on the side of like you know hey man
thanks for the effort but I got to make
this happen now and I know I'm the
person that I need I need a motivator I
need a battery I'm otherwise I'm just a
guy like everybody else like I got a lot
of great ideas but I never get to put
them into play unless there's somebody I
can turn to to be like can you build the
infrastructure can you actually make
this happen
Scott Mosier did that for years for me
Jason's wife Jordan currently does
Jordan Monsanto whenever I'm just like
hey I need to do this she kind of builds
it and stuff so for me I try to find the
most powerful useful person I can and
buddy up to those people and then I
don't hit road bumps like that but in
this very specific instance of an artist
who's not working on your schedule it's
maybe it's time to get a different
artist that's that's what I would do but
it's yeah I get that life happens and
and I I'm sympathetic to that but are
they are ladies paid or no oh yeah of
course that's a weird one then and I
just keep having oh yeah I'll do that
tonight I'll do that this weekend I'll
do that next week and that seems to be
where I'm at and I don't really know
where to go mm yeah I mean that's a
rough one because most of the times if
you're doing sort of small press
comments you're all doing it for free
you do it because you love it and
passion is how you make that sort of
stuff go that's that's the juice for
that not crazy but passion and but if
you're paying a dude and he's not doing
a job then you fired that dude and you
pay somebody else and and if you if you
can't find somebody who will do the work
for money then I mean made me and I
don't want to say that whatever you're
doing might not be the thing that's
that's attracting them but there's
artists out there who do way
more work than I'm sure you were asking
for for free you know and there's got to
be out there somebody out there he'll do
it for money even if it's the worst
thing in the world not saying that it is
but I mean I wrote for DC for awhile and
some of that stuff wasn't great I wrote
for Marvel for a while some of that
stuff wasn't great some of the big to
work is not great well you get paid and
you do the work you know so like if
you're doing something that that you're
passionate about and if the person can't
feel that passion and doesn't want that
money then find somebody else
but for now you win some [ __ ] tickets
[Applause]
where are we going next JC one set or
lose a Buffy statue there you go forty X
that's the way where we going hey hey
how can you really doing yes that guy
what's a sprint [ __ ] him that's true he
left was it a big deal when he left we
didn't want to pay his contract anymore
they actually paid him to not work we're
getting some inside [ __ ] dope man him
to not do any more acting stuff and then
when that contract was done he went
straight to sprint what do you know
about the progressive lady spokespeople
so with how Justice League's doing in
the theaters do you think they released
the Snyder version for home ah great
question you win tickets instantly for
that because it allows us to talk about
this I there have been a there's a
petition online with something like two
hundred fifty thousand signatures saying
put out the Snyder cut I I think it's
ridiculous not to like show the movie
sell the version of the movie that
people are familiar with theatrically
wait six months and then [ __ ] hit him
with the Snyder vision because it's not
like what's the worst that can happen
everybody's like you [ __ ] up and
Warner Brothers like yeah I guess but
it's in their rearview they're working
on something else so it's just another
stream of revenue for him I think he'd
be back [ __ ] crazy pun intended for them
to not put out Zak's vision which I've
read an article about thank you for
bringing it up and
I've [ __ ] saved it on my phone god
dammit I hope it's there still was it
the director of photography no it was a
breakdown of what's missing from the
movie everything read Zack Snyder's
version and all deleted scenes oh come
on don't freeze up on me now oh my god
hold on hold on hold on here we go
okay read snacks in Zack Snyder's
version and although I'm not going to
read you the script but these scenes
were done before reshoots and were shown
to WB executives let me see
aka the the writer says the idiots who
don't appreciate art I mean it's as the
peace comes from superhero talk site so
wordpress.com so obviously their various
written by Haroon Sharif and he's got
opinions to say the least but most
importantly we're not here for the
opinions we're here for the what he
knows
he said longer began the opening was
longer began with Bruce recruiting
Aquaman it was basically the same scene
in the theatrical version however some
lines were added by Whedon and some Zack
bits were cut Aquaman was originally
more resilient and shut off to Bruce
here deleted Barry Allen saving iris
west by breaking the glass remember that
shot of him poking through the glass
apparently his old [ __ ] scene of him
saving iris West meeting iris West gone
longer history lesson but just by some
bits what I was most surprised by the
author says but what WB cutout dialogue
by the Green Lantern Zeus and Ares yes
Ares was there too so on the battlefield
when they flashed back and [ __ ] that
Green Lantern said something and so did
Zeus and so did Ares they cut all that
[ __ ] they had a couple lines each as did
Robin right it was in the movie and
Hippolyta as well Hippolyta we saw
operative like Robin rights credited
even though she's nowhere to be seen in
the movie than will they shot it they
just kept the action in and clicked out
all the dialogue deleted after taking
the mother box from Thomas key
Steppenwolf actually talks to the Box
his mother Hagar his essence is alive in
the mother boxes and bringing them all
together would unleash your powers
finally given Steppenwolf an edge over
his uncle Darkseid that is what his plan
was originally I thought for sure they
would keep that scene because they use
dialogue from that scene in the trailers
where he said no protectors here no
lanterns this world will fall it was
part of that scene but they cut that out
deleted cyborgs previous life he plays a
great football match that his mother
attends afterwards they drive home
Victor is angry that his dad never made
it while his mother tries to console him
Victor just keeps getting angrier and
lashing out loose control the car causes
a fiery crash so that's how he got
injured and his killed and his mom got
killed in the process
longer the Gordon scene up on the roof
had a little setup that I didn't see in
the theatrical version
Gordon dismisses a junkie and tells him
to get better at life before another cop
comes to him with drawings of the
parademons remember when he said that
and he said when he first met Wonder
Woman he asked if she's the same woman
he keeps seeing reports in London about
many a cyborg how do you eat do you even
need to and they cut all that deleted
after the attack on Atlantis Aquaman
consults with Mira and volcko so what's
his name
Willem Dafoe is playing volcko they had
a whole [ __ ] scene where they talk
about what they should do next Mira
wants Arthur's stay as king because she
quote doesn't trust form so they [ __ ]
name-dropped Ormond they cut that [ __ ]
out
boku wants him to do what his heart says
aquaman confesses that he feels a
responsibility to help the people of
Earth so there's some more backstory on
Atlantis other than him gone well I'm
gonna need something from you which I
guess is the suit of well he was wearing
or the Quinn den or whatever yeah the
truck wasn't it treinen though it has
five so there was that a Quinn didn't
pensioners Quinn den right okay deleted
the league visits the Batcave Alfred has
humorous reactions to the league Bruce
so Alfred like just gone oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh they cut all that Bruce Wayne talks
about a nightmare he had he believes
that Steppenwolf will try to resurrect
power of Superman and then they must do
it first unless they want to fight an
evil Kryptonian - so they have they were
beating Steppenwolf to reviving Superman
which makes a lot more sense doesn't it
change
Superman's resurrection was only
possible because cyborg detects foreign
genetic material in his DNA
aka the Codex remember the Codex from
Anna steel that was playing as part of
the plot that's gone this is the final
confirmation needed that Superman can be
brought back to life after all then the
revival happens pretty much the same
deleted this is in the middle of the
[ __ ] movie ready for this Deathstroke
breaks Lex out of prison why the [ __ ]
would you cut that out oh my god I
questioned everybody sanity they part
ways because the cops are hot on their
trail decided to meet up later at a
location they discussed which was the PS
seen on the [ __ ] boat deleted Kent
farm now this sounds like they butchered
the [ __ ] out of this Superman brings
Lois here however he is still very
confused after he wakes up not knowing
what's happening bystanders are looking
at him and clicking his photo this
confuses him further and he actually
tries to attack the civilians with laser
eyes before Lois manages to calm him
down Superman tells her that the voices
won't shut up later Martha showed Martha
Martha shows up and here and and she
does a version of her remember she did a
Man of Steel which is like you're on an
island you hear the sound of my voice
she talks him down again which ties in
to the other [ __ ] movie they took out
all the [ __ ] the tie back which I think
was like that's part of the vision it
makes me a little mad Kevin Costner was
also in the movie pock Kent was also on
the [ __ ] farm in some fantasy
sequence they cut that [ __ ] out Paquette
talks about embracing who you really are
and says you know what maybe you could
have saved me after all no I just said
with that part
also there's plenty of room on this door
jack
he tells Clark that you have to make
peace with who you are you have the
power to change the world and you could
do that as anyone good character or bad
Clark finally embraces Superman as part
of him when Lois walks out Clark
confirms their engagement Lois breaks
down because she wasn't strong enough
then Martha comes out to as Clark
decides to help the league and he flies
off that's how it happened in the
version they saw deleted Clark heads up
to meet Alfred and get his suit remember
the [ __ ] shot from the trailer where
Alford's like thank god you're here
let's hope you're not too late that's
what it was he came to get his [ __ ]
suit that's gone deleted Steppenwolf
second conversation with Hera now that
he is all three mother boxes her return
to this world can begin so she actually
speaks at that point fourteen they said
changed Bruce's conversation with Diana
after Superman Returns Diana comes into
pop Bruce's shoulder and tend to his
injuries remember that Bruce reveals
that he's willing to die to save the
world in fact that he deserves to die
because of what he's done he's killed
people and nothing not even as hate for
Superman can justify killing like that
holy [ __ ] man like that's something
every Batman fan wanted to hear
based on Superman and Batman V Superman
really like he's killing [ __ ]
and Brandon I'm like crazy so they
actually made up for it but boom that
got stripped out Diana tells him he's
changed now but Bruce remains adamant
that he can only atone himself by
sacrificing his life changed Bruce's
Batmobile is heading to certain death
before the finale
when Wonder Woman and Aquaman interfere
and save his life they tell him that
dying in battle won't do you anything
and he must live to keep the fight going
so we had a suicidal crazy [ __ ]
Batman who was like I got a make up for
being such a [ __ ] in the last movie
and they they cut it out alternate
ending we were shown this guy said he
saw a version of the movie
cyborg tries to separate the mother
boxes while Hagar keeps trying to talk
him away furious Steppenwolf grabs
cyborg and rips him apart essentially
killing him that's not in the movie
didn't he rip him though I saw him like
poses leg off yeah and this version he
just [ __ ] shredded him and this woman
is nodding in the corner cuz this is
probably the same version that she's
version that you saw long to that she
couldn't talk about last week because
there's NDA's and [ __ ] this
[ __ ] all over the web I
promised them I went talk today wait
yeah that stuff was in there that's the
version that you saw the one that's out
now yes and in terms of seeing both what
do you think I like the first one better
I mean at least it's all one vision
right again they should put out that
[ __ ] movie changed Superman joins the
fight and teams up with the league to
defeat Steppenwolf however at one point
Steppenwolf tries to tempt Superman into
joining his army ready for this this
made me so [ __ ] angry and we see
Darkseid for the first time in
Superman's vision and we see flashes of
the nightmare footage that Batman had in
Batman V Superman however Superman snaps
back out of it and delivers the final
blow to defeat Steppenwolf was that in
the version you saw you saw Darkseid
what did it look like kind of like the
finish but not really not fully finished
goddamn it deleted Steppenwolf is killed
by Darkseid on apocalypse you didn't see
that Darkseid intends to come to earth
to meet the Kryptonian he says you
remember they were talking about doing
two Justice League oh yeah I'm telling
you part two was gonna be [ __ ] this
now we're found out they were setting it
up for Darkseid deleted Aquaman meets
mirror off the village coast and agrees
to come back Barry steps into the
library iris smiles at him so there was
little PS with everybody
deleted Bruce and Barry plays Victor's
body in the Batcave Bruce comments that
his organic tissue is dead but it may be
possible to reignite his mechanical
parts Barry promises to help however he
can so [ __ ] did cyborg die in here
version he didn't die in here version
deleted Louis introduces Perry White to
Clark Kent aka Superman so he was in the
movie as well and the original after
credits scene that were
chaton principal photography was Bruce
being woken in the night in his lake
house by a green light I'm with you [ __ ]
it by a green light and being visited by
tomar ray and Kilowog holy [ __ ] it was
cut early on during post come on man so
that right there
like yes I think they should release
that version even if it's unfinished
even if they're like I think this public
is educated enough to be like look it's
an unfinished film they're not gonna
give us the it's not going to look like
a big-budget movie some shits gonna be
in final stages they can even put in
like storyboard frames if they have to
but let people see that version clearly
the dude had a vision it sounds like it
tied in well with Man of Steel and with
Batman V Superman like each one that
seemed like they tried to course-correct
along the way and I know it wasn't
originally conceived as a trilogy but
they kind of got it to be one it sounds
like until the Joss Whedon stuff which
again I'm not [ __ ] on the Joss
Whedon stuff I love that [ __ ] Wonder
Woman lasso scene and that's only there
because of that guy but that [ __ ]
sounded like a DC comic fans wet dream
man that the like here's Darkseid
[ __ ] you know oh my god now I'm
angry anyway do you think they'll
release it I think they absolutely
release it I mean I have eight versions
of Evil Dead 2 at home and if I can if
they keep releasing those [ __ ]
every like four years 10th anniversary
1500 20th anniversary yes I have a box
set with four different versions of
Brazil in it but Criterion put out years
and years ago I got about nineteen
Terminator twos
so metal boxes wooden boxes [ __ ] no
box whatsoever man like I got every
version of that DVD they can get money
out of these be honestly they can be
pricks him out of two of their like it's
gonna be a hundred bucks we'd be like
fine I'll [ __ ] pay it [ __ ] you give
me that yeah and there's about it on the
Internet because I think that you know
again I have no idea what the thought
processes were beyond just having to
realize that we were not going to do
Justice League - so you've gotta
cauterize this movie here and so if
we're never gonna get this a dark side
don't even tip - dark side but he does
say dark side in the movie he does one
time like kind of passing you know like
I don't I don't know what kind of
decisions went into that process but
given that the theatrical cut is out
you've done the job you were supposed to
do which is make this palatable to the
masses now yeah for a hundred bucks
the fans would buy this right and they
would see what kind of support that it
gets you definitely win some tickets for
that we got a lot of content out of that
I don't I don't think it's the first
thing out I don't think it rolls out
with the theatrical release right but I
think that you know a couple months
after like next Christmas you absolutely
find the [ __ ] hardcore Zack Snyder
vision do we we got one more set of
tickets like you got a Richard Donner
Superman cut years later why not do his
ex nighter excellent a cease pointing
out a bar owner JC is pointing out that
we finally did get the dick downer cut
where you saw the gauntlet all the [ __ ]
that they cut out of the Superman movies
so yeah we finally got [ __ ] well done
so maybe let's hope that they know that
there's clearly a fan base they've got a
bunch of names on a petition
it would just be obstinate to not put
out Snyder's vision again it doesn't
have to be finished it's not like I
could see there are gonna be like in
order to show you his vision we'd have
to spend another 10 15 million I think
this audience is totally fine with like
dude I'll see storyboards if a Parshin
of it as storyboards that's [ __ ] fine
just to see all that footage that they
described that i just read about in that
article i don't care if it's like
haphazardly put together with imagery of
my mom [ __ ] my father I'm watching
all of it
they can't Unseld that to me let's shall
we do one more for these tickets then
get out of here Bob
yes my lantern gets asked question ask
away my friend nice brother all right
so after all that can you guys describe
a writers and filmmakers what would be
your ideal sequel to the Justice League
Wow all right Farren that definitely
gets your tickets here we go I made my
my sequel to the Justice League I mean
you know we have two sequel eyes the one
they did not the one that was intended
the one that I saw in a theatre that
means you can't really do Darkseid
I would I would probably last week I
talked about like why can't they do
Starro the Conqueror and then they
referenced Starro on flash last week
like wally west came back he's like I
fought a starfish from another planet
that was a cool so I honestly like I
talked about before that I love the
Justice League story that Grant Morrison
wrote years ago Rock of Ages which
involves all the characters and and you
can take it in wonderful weird
directions you could lose the whirligig
that if you wanted the philosopher's
stone which kind of starts the story but
I think doing that stuff that's the one
I'd lean toward the most but I bet you
the real writer amongst us has a better
idea you know I don't know there's
there's a part of me that what was that
Mark Waid saw was a Tower of Babel tower
Babel tower Babel that's where they came
up with the idea of Batman's got files
on everybody right right like that
Batman knows how to kill everybody in
the league except for Wonder Woman
because she has no weakness right that's
the story I want to see I want to see I
want to see Bruce Wayne for some reason
in determined taking out the Justice
League I mean that's kind of what Batman
V Superman was it was well on his way I
love you who but yeah like I feel like
at this point I want internal threats
not external threats I don't again never
need to see anybody talking to chasing
after a question for a box
yeah no more boxes no more boxes no more
no more weird no more we just get all
three together or well rule whatever the
[ __ ] like it's changing the world to the
world we wanted to be now I want it to
be personal I I see I figure it is
interesting but now my appetite is
whetted for a legion of doom movie so
I'd rather see them fighting not one
threat but [ __ ] nine like nine
supervillains all in [ __ ] costumes
that's how you put that franchise back
on the right man like you just go look
we get it you just want to see [ __ ]
live-action versions of the comic-book
characters and cartoons you grew up with
our bad
we thought we could tell you an adult
story that was really depressing I don't
know what we were thinking you're a
video game character in the middle of it
totally it's like just give us what we
want man I can't tell you how [ __ ]
thrilled I was as goofy as it was seeing
Deathstroke wearing that big-ass costume
and walking on the boat and [ __ ] I was
like give me more of that man give me an
even goofier black manta costume give me
[ __ ] toy man solomon grundy do the
Legion of Doom for my childhood man like
just put it all up there I don't care if
it looks like cosplay anymore I just
want to see live-action versions of the
[ __ ] I love there's a great cover story
in Vanity Fair which they threw a bunch
of pictures up online today of for the
Marvel characters so you get to see the
whole [ __ ] world laid out across
there the covers but why did I bring it
up [ __ ] there was something in the
article I read that was really a salient
point where I was like was that the
Russos talking about what DC needs to
get it back on track no they did yeah
what'd they say they need a Kevin Feige
okay the secret sauce yeah like of
course yeah they do they literally need
Kevin Feige but they said something in
the article that was to the point I
guess what I was getting that [ __ ] I
forget but just serve the audience man
like you know like fanservice there
ain't nothing wrong if I'm DC at this
point I'm just like here's your favorite
oh that's what it was like I'm talking
about like show me all the characters I
love they said in the re I think his bob
iger said in the article he
like we're about like it they're
promoting of Avengers infinity Wars
where it's looking more and more likely
like we're gonna lose some major heroes
and stuff and what they said was like
we've got [ __ ] two thousand four
thousand characters we haven't even
touched in the Marvel Library so going
forward like they're preparing you for
like you enjoy Ironman because it ain't
gonna be Ironman forever enjoy thoradine
gonna be thor forever in Captain America
like we got a lot more toys to play with
and we're telling an ongoing [ __ ]
story which on one level makes me sad
because I'm like no I'll watch [ __ ]
Tony Stark read the [ __ ] phone book
and in some of those movies we literally
do but at the same time I respect the
like hey let's let's put some stakes in
let's let's keep this going for decades
so that it's we're not rebooting like I
don't think Marvel ever reboots I think
they just keep telling more stories and
introducing more characters and I like
that business model you yeah I mean
that's what success lets you do success
lets you lean into the success and lets
you keep doing the thing that you know
is working but finding ways to innovate
you know not getting bored with it not
risking an audience trying to like oh
man another one of these god dammit this
is like Thor 2 I don't want it for three
and then you give Thor 3 like oh [ __ ]
nothing like what I expected
I feel like DC first needs to get their
feet they need to get a solid foundation
and give us a couple of adventures give
us a couple movies invest us in these
characters beyond the fact that I have a
built in investment for Batman like
that's what it is right that's where it
is you have to earn my money and they
are right now counting on my
proclivities for this stuff they know
we're gonna go right they are not
earning my attention and once they start
doing that then you can get deep cuts
then you can you've got an audience by
that by the brain by the heart do
whatever the [ __ ] you want what you have
them there they got to be careful that
they don't Batman Wonder Woman as well
like you know Batman they're like oh
[ __ ] this works let's [ __ ] do it to
death and since we love Batman we don't
really [ __ ] but they got to be careful
they don't do that too
as well like they caught lightning in a
bottle and [ __ ] and they're not just
gonna like beat it to death
hopefully they service the character I'm
saying the well right now character and
patty Jenkins are tied together holy and
that's the way it should stay you know
but like the Berlanti verse did that
work like they got us on board with
those versions of these characters to
the point where you can do you know the
black mercy stuff you can do [ __ ]
martian manhunter
or you do what they're doing this week
which is a crisis on earth x they're
doing of crossover across all the CW
shows started tonight on Supergirl
continued on arrow and then tomorrow
night it's on flash and legends of
tomorrow telling one story about them
fighting Nazi versions of themselves and
stuff yeah like once we care we'll go
down a long [ __ ] road with you and
the road is gonna be windy and weird and
[ __ ] up and I'm gonna stop at places
you never would have stopped at you
would buy [ __ ] you'd never buy you need
stuff you hate but you kind of like it
cuz where I'm from this [ __ ] road
trip but unless you invest me in that
everything's got to be [ __ ] vanilla
and that's where they are now it's true
when you think about - it's like if you
do it right if you crack a formula you
can go forever like that supernatural
show I think they're in their 40th
season and it's it's like a quiet
stealth killer it's like it has a
hardcore art ardent audience that has
taken it passed like ten seasons until
eleven twelve at this point thirty
thirteen [ __ ] seasons man that's like
take a page out of those people's books
far as DC I'd be like how do you [ __ ]
create brand loyalty over 13 years
clearly these people know what they're
doing put them on these [ __ ] movies I
mean Smallville went for what 11 yeah
you know like if you if you give people
something that they can reliably turn
into and get what they're expecting to
get and feel good about it feel rewarded
by it they will follow you forever I
know we make it sound so easy like we've
ever done it do we have it but it seems
easy you know and I'm saying it from the
outside as people who enjoy this [ __ ]
when you analyze it it's like really it
just comes down to the story like that's
what Marvel stood and I hate to you know
we'll be doing this forever but you hate
to bring up you know raise one and low
or the other or whatever the [ __ ] but
you know Marvel Studios just understands
like how to do it whereas right now
DC is kind of I mean figuring it out
which is weird and frustrating because
they owned this space for so long like
in the 70s with Superman in the late 80s
all through the 90s with Batman in the
arts with [ __ ] more Batman Batman
Batman Batman and now we have these
discussions where we're like how can
they catch up how can they and it seems
weird man
well because Marvel realized and I think
some of it had to do with jaws I'm gonna
have to do with Kevin but these are soap
opera stories yeah at their core and
soap operas are the longest-running form
of entertainment in the world General
Hospital's been on the air for 70
[ __ ] years yeah and they've all been
[ __ ] each other and they've been
[ __ ] each other there's vampires and
ice princesses and laser beams and jewel
heists and who gives a [ __ ] but because
people get what they're looking for I
mean you can twist that story any number
of ways you want for 50 years those
things have been on the air if you
follow a soap opera model and just that
guy's [ __ ] that person and that
person's [ __ ] that person and that
guy killed that person but it's really
in love with that person and you just
build that [ __ ] story
you can add vampires if you want but I
mean DC has yet said get us on that soap
up a ride they're not they're not
baiting the hook in the way we need to
be baited to go down that road with them
mm-hmm
what a down note to go out on that's
true let's see yeah it is
and the show has gone on so [ __ ] long
I believe it is literally the day oh is
the longest one I think we've done so
far you all have a good time this
evening it's a wonderful show we got a
wonderful home right here it's going
bill and they give it up for JC and the
folks here it's come with it give it up
for the man I stand next to my Anna
makes it so much fun and easy to talk
about [ __ ] that we have no skin in the
game whatsoever we could be very
judgmental about mr. mark Bernard ladies
John and that is fat man on Batman for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard tune in next week same fad time
same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith hi folks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you